and the lady who is lighting up the
internet we already know okay if you
haven't seen her you're gonna see her
right now it is pearl
yeah there you go there she is a woman
that is lighting up the internet today
we are going to be talking about where
are the real men but
before we even get started tell them
tell them if you've watched two or more
of our videos uh-huh
and you haven't subscribed
then we have what beef what do we have
well beef okay so you better start doing
that right now over to you pearl
okay guys so we have a couple
announcements the first being that we
got a new apartment yeah
everyone clapped yay
so um thank you for everyone that has
signed up for our memberships that's a
big part of why we're able to afford the
apartment that we're going to get if you
want to see a behind-the-scenes look of
this dope-ass penthouse we got in london
um sign up for our memberships because
it's going to be a members only
vlog which we have three four tiers now
and our fourth year you actually get a
one-on-one coaching session with me once
a month and at the 10 tier that the
pregame plus that is where the vlog will
be
on top of that the second half of this
chat is going to be members only today
so join our memberships because on top
of being a part of the chat you also get
the vlogs
um also go follow my instagram
just.pearlythings
um
and our jess who's our member of the
week
do we have one do you have a member of
the week this week
it's not it's not going to be sentience
again no no no no jess is coming where's
my camera blessing yeah she's right
there she's right now
hey guys our member of the week is ata
ata was showing up a lot in the 24 hour
live stream okay a great member so shout
out to you 18.
okay um also if you guys want to come on
the show dm eddie on the link to his
instagram's in the description
so today we have i think the biggest
panel we've literally ever had that's
right yes
shout out eddie um the biggest panel
we've ever had so why don't we go around
everyone say
their name their age their relationship
status um
and a fun fact starting with you we'll
go around this way and then we'll go to
the people in the kitchen
my name is adam i'm 28 years old i've
got a girlfriend in a relationship
fun fact about me
i started a brand called beard gang
members
and i've been connecting bid since 2019.
my name is hannah i'm 27 i'm in a
relationship and a fun fact about me is
i used to compete for team gb in
powerlifting
oh that's so cool
that is a fun fact
my name is maya i'm 23. um
wait fun fact what was before the fun
fact are you single
um i'm single but at the start of
something interesting um and
my fun fact is that i'm a spoken word
poet okay
hello my name is tavana i am 26 um
i am single
i am single and a fun fact about myself
is
i own my own quiz night live page on
instagram
okay
quiz night a quiz night yeah i go live
on instagram and i do a quiz night a
winner gets a gift card and everything
like that oh that's fun yeah
interactive game my name is mohammed i'm
18. and
fun oh i'm single but
it's a little bit complicated
uh fun fact about me is i write my free
time
you write you like books oh okay cool
yeah
cool and then um
let's do the kitchen because they'll
come in and people be like who are they
yeah yeah so grab grab the mic and then
yeah yeah so then and then pass it to
the next person right my name is rasheed
um i'm 24. i'm single and a fun fact
about me is uh
i do jiu jitsu muay thai football and
futsal every week
okay
hello guys um my name is shekna i am 29
i am single and fun fact
one of my exes
took me out
to a poor dance club
what is that to a pole dancing club oh a
pole dancing club
that that's the fun fact you picked
we know where your mind is okay
was it was it a good experience that was
yeah oh it'd be too cool that's the
beginning but at the end yeah
okay
um and you might want to scoot in the
court's not that long so if you want to
yeah yeah just so
hi my name's amira i'm 25 years old i'm
single
and i'm a rapper
oh you can me too
you ain't probably
why are you laughing i don't get the
joke all right
anyways we can like rap later we can
like do the bar thing oh my god
my name's rachel i'm 25 i'm taken and
the fun fact about me is um i like to do
shrooms
okay
wow we got some fun we got some
interesting people today very fun fact
we got shrooms a beard connector quizzer
wrapper dance clap the wrapper so let's
get let's get started folks um
this episode today is about
where are the real men all right so
it's a subject it's something that men
hear a lot i guess
we normally hear it from women that say
a real man would be ex or a real man
would do this
so the first question is
what is a real man
anyone answer i think like here's how i
would define it you know in the dating
space there's like high value man high
value women so like my definition would
be four things the first is he's got
good discipline in all areas of life so
like fitness finances whatever it is the
second is he's got good leadership so
like he can lead not only like his
career but also his relationship
the third is he's got good morals
because a lot of the time we see real
men as men who just make loads of money
but if you're super loaded but you don't
have good morals does that really make
you a real man
right so um those are the three things
and then the fourth i would say
is in the context of dating a man who
has that provider and that protector
mindset
okay that's all facts to be fair what do
you guys think keep going listen just
jump in when you want to jump in front
of those facts i would um
a man that sticks to his word for me
that's very important um if he obviously
is a man of his word he trusts himself
therefore it gives me the ability to be
able to trust him and i would really
look for that in a man as a quality so
yeah i also think a real man is someone
that's not afraid to speak their mind
so i mean someone that can just say
what's on their mind get it off their
chest without
fearing about the repercussion that's
exactly what i was going to say for me
it's like i don't have like a criteria
but i would say it's honesty like even
if you do bad things if i if if you can
be honest with me or you're just honest
in general that is something that i'll
always respect someone for whether or
not they've done something good or bad
to me i don't believe you
are you serious yeah because women don't
want honesty no for me it's the best
thing they do if if you're honest with a
woman if a woman's asking you a question
generally do i look fat in this what are
you gonna say
women if women liked honest men then why
does every girl have an ex that cheated
on her
but when i say it i mean it is
we're looking at a good man yeah so say
for example
my perception of a good man i'm thinking
of what he's going to bring to me so
that's not necessarily
well you can say how i look in this or
whatever but i'm talking in terms of
relationship if i've asked you something
in terms of relationship like what
qualities you bring or what you've done
in the past or what you want in the
future and you lie to me i'm not going
to respect you so you want your mind to
be honest with you at all times yeah
white white lies
so like i have a question about that
what if he's honest but he's not the
kind of man who's like
super mission driven and he's lazy and
he's just not living up to his potential
yeah i can't i can't settle for that but
he's honest with himself yeah i
appreciate the honesty thank you but no
thanks you know i think you need to be
honest but it should tone a voice and
the way you come across with your
honesty so you need to be tactile
so
say for instance like the question babe
do i look fat in this
you would then say
nah
you don't look fat in this but
it may highlight your insecurities in
this way so maybe blah blah blah blah
blah
blah
blah blah blah
blah would i like that well you need to
you need to have a sugarcoat a little
bit too much no i know you're you're
turning you're turning men into women
women
no
because that's how your girlfriend would
say it to you
right
no you like your man like you like your
girlfriend
you want a day to bed
do you want to date a dad
i don't want to date a [ __ ] but i want
to date a man that has good
communication skills so if you know how
to speak with me that's how i want to be
spoken to no don't say baby look fat
because i'm like right am i fat i'm
gonna start looking in the mirror and
being insecure but if you know i don't
like certain things and this highlights
that and you can tell me i call it
highlights this all right cool i'll
change i i want my man to say you look
like a whale
yeah yeah yeah i just i just feel like
wow you don't want a guy that's gonna
lie to you like if i look fat tell me i
look fat
if you told me i look like a whale honey
i will be waking you up at three o'clock
in the morning be like really like do i
actually it would just motivate me i get
on the treadmill and start running
up your chest temperature this is one of
the reasons
i say we've said it so many times women
don't want honest men like they say they
do but if a man i i draw 100 no i truly
believe that if men were honest with
women women wouldn't like men so never
because you have no idea what goes on
inside ourselves what it is i think it's
just honesty and the important things
that actually count like things like do
i look fat in this they want white lies
they don't want to hear the honest truth
but sorry if you're if you're dating if
you're dating what are you thinking
of dating like they want honesty at that
point right or like the important things
but just the little things here and
there they don't really care about that
what were you going to say i was content
i need my man to be honest
yeah i need the brutal truth so you want
your mind today that you're fat yeah
tell me that's right that's rare though
that's rare you're right you're alive
your mind the minority or the majority
of women minority yeah okay that's fact
she's minor yeah because
if you sugarcoat it then i'm not going
to change nothing so so i mean i'm
trying to change myself life you think i
look yeah i don't want to look fat so
tell me that yeah so i can get upset and
get in a gym so she she'll be that girl
on the treadmill at 2 a.m
so i have a question um since we can
determine um what a real man is do you
think that men have the right to say
girls that are [ __ ] and fat aren't
real women
no yeah yes 100 yeah yeah because the
same way they dictate what a real man
should be
like it's basically societal standards
right so you have moral standards and
societal standards and just because you
might think that like girls they don't
agree with like moral standards of men
and they think societal standards stand
supreme but i i feel like
whatever you agree with morally dictates
what a real whatever opposite gender
should be so if a woman sleeps around a
lot i don't really think that's right so
you think men can tell women what a real
woman should be and women should tell
men what a real man should be i think as
long as it's their preference i think
it's allowed
who said no
no why why
well i feel like when it comes to women
it's always things about what we're
choosing to do in our daily life that
makes us a problem whereas with men we
don't say oh because you do this
that's a problem yes more qualities yeah
you do yeah you do if you want what if
he just wants to play video games and
work a 12 an hour job maybe i'm that
doesn't make him a bad person it's just
what he wants to do but in the same way
you could say if a girl won't if a girl
if a girl won't get on the treadmill
that's what she chooses to do not not
get on the treadmill and not put the
fork down i think the problem that i
have is that some things that apply to
women don't apply to men and some things
that apply to men don't apply so there
are double standards
do you think
do you think men and women are the same
no um
i feel like we are but i feel like
society doesn't
when you say when you say we are in what
what in what ways do you say i feel like
if there's some there's nothing that a
man can do that a woman can't do yes
there is
like what like what then why is
if that's if that's true then why are
men 99 of the people on oil rigs
why are men 99 of the people that
lay bricks
yeah but that's because that's how it's
always been in society you know what i'm
saying you're saying men and women can
do the same things right physically yeah
right so if so if physically a bunch of
women decided to build a house and a
bunch of men decided to build a house
do you think it would take the same
amount of time probably not but that's
only because
i think like that that's the question of
efficiency
right because we're not the same because
we're not the same we have differences
we do have differences yeah go ahead
we've only been allowed to vote for the
last hundred years
if we had the same chances as men
we'd probably be running [ __ ] right now
do you know why we couldn't vote do you
do you know do you know why we couldn't
vote
why no so most women actually didn't
want the right to vote because it came
with the responsibility of getting
drafted so if you voted that means you
had to go fight in war what feminism
always has done is saying give women
freedom without the responsibility that
comes with it and so so the reason
wasn't because we were oppressed or we
couldn't do things it was it was
literally because girls said um i don't
want to you know be on the front lines
in vietnam
but i think society has changed though
even though i'm i'm a bit in the middle
yeah i agree with like the old-fashioned
so when but when you said like women
would be running things right yeah i
mean as in there'd be a fair chance but
generally women don't want to run things
they want men to be in charge yeah 100
do you know what i mean so it's like
there's this whole conversation about oh
yeah women are bosses and da da and we
can do the same thing men can do you
don't want to do it
men have to take charge and just do it
well it's generally women don't want to
do that so it's it's often like women
want the freedom and and they want the
benefits that come with with
old orders so they want they want like
the traditional men the guys that pay
for anything but we we're not
traditional women so we're not virgins
anymore we're not young anymore when we
get married and so it's like we take
away the things that men value while
offering like we require more and offer
less yes
but i think like nowadays there are
still some women who have that
traditional mindset like maybe they
don't save having sex until marriage but
they still are willing to contribute to
the relationship like if he provides
financially then the woman she should be
willing to bring other things to the
relationship and that's how i see is 50
50 is not like everyone contributes 50
of the same things it's they both
contribute 100 but in different facets
when you say that
what do you think a woman should be
bringing to a relationship
so when i look at like what a lot of men
want and you guys like let me know if
i'm wrong i think that for a man who is
super mission oriented and he's driven
he wants a few things from his woman
right the first is he wants her to be
supportive like he wants her to be his
number one hype woman right even if like
no one else believes in him
the second is he probably wants a woman
who's in her feminine meaning that she's
okay with being led she's okay with
letting him make the decisions because
she trusts him
and i also think that men want a woman
who
makes them feel wanted and appreciated
and respected
so i know it all sounds really like
simple and absolutely no because we're
simple creatures so you actually touched
on quite a bit it's very few things yeah
yeah but the issue is simple yeah and i
think like the issue is nowadays those
things even though they're simple in
theory they're hard for men to find
because there are a lot of women who
view
you know
this strong independent woman vibe as
like some badge of honor so i think it's
more and more rare for a man to find a
woman who's in touch with the feminine
side who respects him and who you know
doesn't get offended when he tries to
help her
and we also lack purity in youth do you
know what the average age of first
marriage in the uk is
it's 31.
wow so so and
we like i think most men when i when i
ask them like how many bodies is too
many bodies they'll say 10 or less
typically
and a 31 year old that i ask you're
gonna have so many more than two i ask
girls i'll be like how many bodies do
you think the average 31 year old has
and they'll say 20 30. and it's like
we're we're not offering the things that
men value anymore but we're still asking
for traditional outcomes um
so you see sorry go on but are we
speaking of today's men because yeah
today's men a lot of today's men are not
bringing
what you lot are basically saying a lot
of men can't speak on it they don't have
discipline a lot of men don't have
morals a lot of men don't bring
[ __ ] ras to the table
and i feel like a woman i'm speaking for
myself i can't speak for everybody else
i am someone that i like to hold myself
as independent and likes to be a
go-getter and i want what i want but i
also want a man to be able to hold me
down to be able to
bring things to the table to be able to
make me feel like i can be submissive
and i feel like it takes a real
a real man or a right man for myself to
do that but a lot of men of today are
not let me finish a lot of men of today
are not bringing that so therefore i
don't feel like i can be that kind of
woman because a lot of men that i'm
coming across
don't make i feel like i have to have my
back up
you go another one no no no don't come
forward
okay is that reflective of men or your
ability to pick men um
because because i go from i go for i've
had i've had my fair share yeah i've had
for me now your fair share of men i've
yeah definitely i've dated honey i've
dated and i will not i will not shy away
from that i've had the aggressor the
alpha male that don't work for me nice
guys for me at the moment are not
finishing last and
it's not i don't know why are you single
there's so many nice guys why am i
single because i am working on myself my
love that's why i'm single you know what
that's actually cold
a woman that says i'm working on myself
is actually cold that i just want to
kind of be in the streets
not necessarily that's what it's called
i'm busy no i'm saying to men no because
what i'm trying to say is a woman says
i'm trying to work on myself that just
means i just want to be single and just
kind of [ __ ] around yeah because if a
guy came out come on if leonard if a guy
that looked like leonardo dicaprio asked
you out tomorrow it's cap if a guy had
every single thing that you wanted and
you felt like if you didn't jump on this
you were going to miss out on a really
good opportunity you you wouldn't you
wouldn't say no because he's not a
dicaprio at the same time but i'm saying
that's what i'm saying like it's because
you don't have the options you want
i don't have the options i want at the
same time i still hold myself as a
certain kind of woman and if i wanted to
have a man that leonardo dicaprio i
would also like to have be a woman that
is on the same level where i can offer
the same things that he can offer me
something so you know what you're saying
about the independence right oh um
what
do you mean independent as in in
yourself or in the relationship
within myself so not in the relationship
because obviously in a relationship it's
partnership it's partnership yes but
when i get to that stage with somebody i
will then have partnership when a man
shows when i come across a man whereby
i'm mentally ready and he's mentally
ready to go on that road with me have
you heard that before no i have not had
that before no not yet but when it comes
i will take it is it is it because it
doesn't exist
like i don't believe it doesn't exist i
grew up with this um disneyland and
fairy tale ending my king night shining
armor will come yeah okay so okay so
i've spoken about this no no that's not
real
i've spoken about this you a lot of
women have been sold a hollywood version
of a relationship right and the bottom
line is the the perfect man that a lot
of women are looking for doesn't
actually exist and so what happens is a
woman a lot of women wait around for
this perfect guy to turn up and he
doesn't actually exist so what happens
is the longer you wait for him to turn
up the older you get
the more your eggs aren't being used
your biological clock starts ticking
because you're work you're waiting for
that perfect man he doesn't exist you
get good men you get bad men you get men
kind of in between and that's and that's
really the choices that you got so
waiting on this you're saying that you
you grew up on like fairy tales and all
this kind of stuff
a lot of women that grew up on fairy
tales and believe that end up old with
cats oh damn well i don't like cats i
like dogs
kevin samuel said what
dog die alone
you mentioned that you um
when you meet someone you have your
guard up straight away yeah and you
don't really show that feminine side to
them straight away so what if
you not showing that side makes them not
want to show you
their full side you know i mean and just
keep you well at arm's length well i
still remain
i guess as feminine as i can be but
there's just certain
doors that don't get unlocked for me
when i was like dating properly
if a girl went showing me like the
things that i needed from
date two
then you just go straight to the bottom
of the pile and then someone else is
there to take the place because what
because you said like your femininity is
kind of conditional it's like the the
real man has to come and make me
feminine if do you know what that would
sound like if a guy said that
the world a real woman has to come and
make me masculine oh i hear that do you
know what i mean it sounds like sorry so
this is some feminine guy that's waiting
on
a woman to come and make him masculine
you wouldn't you wouldn't even be
attracted to that guy
if he had to wait to become a masculine
man hmm it's more so of
okay cool i'm going to go on a whole
tangent so there's these doors and
obviously certain doors need to get
unlocked
right you're with me cool
and i like i'm listening i don't know if
i'm with you but i'm trying to
understand yeah for me needs to get
unlocked and when he shows himself more
as what i value in a man
they open gradually do you think that in
that scenario
you're not supposed to open doors also
or only he has to open up i do believe
so as well it's when the energy aligns
when it connects like i go from energy
and when it's all going together then
one band bob's your uncle so you see
this real man that we're talking about
like have you have you met him have i
met a real man
have i met a real man that's what
everyone else yeah the women have you
met like that real man that you took
that you
my dad's the real yeah but they're all
in relationships
oh
okay so i don't i would say i have like
i would consider my boyfriend as a real
man going off the criteria that i just
gave right but the reason why i think a
lot of women don't find you know in air
quotes real men
is because of their beliefs because i
think it's so easy as women for us to
maybe we've been burnt once or twice and
we've been cheated on and then we have
this belief system that all men are
trash all men cheat all men lie and so
if that's what we believe to be true
then that's what we're going to attract
well you're making you're making the men
of the past pay for your like the guy in
the future pay for the men of your past
and that's like another reason men don't
like older women it's not necessarily
because don't men do that no don't what
don't men do the same thing with women
not so men honestly they take the l and
move on women write whole albums
wait wait a second
men are still holding on to that
heartbreak from when they were
seven years old because she didn't
take his rose or something silly like
that from the second
like they want to be the victim like
every every ex they talk about is always
okay
i'm telling you i talk to men and women
all the time on my show like i do this
four times a week the amount of women
that have a toxic narcissistic ex where
he did everything wrong boohoo blah blah
blah and like men don't do say that men
just say you know what yeah i took it
out okay
because men don't talk that's why
men don't talk and men don't know how to
talk
go ahead can i also say like it's the
lack of accountability of amen the
problem
that causes problems with girls finding
someone they want so they won't see that
it was a problem with this guy
and they won't
say okay this guy was a bad guy let me
move on and become the same a better
person or something like that they'll
choose okay i'm gonna have all these
barriers and now this real man has to
somehow break through it with no code
i'm still being
difficult and
somehow he's meant to show he's a real
man
it doesn't really make sense and it's
quite hard the problem the problem is
yeah most women like the ability to
self-reflect yeah hold on i need to
speak i am so so sorry
women like the excuse me
men do not know how to chat
if we're going to go back for a little
selection please let me finish please
let me finish
if we're going to go back from primary
school i'm talking back in the
playground when boys said i don't cry
i've never cried a day in my life men
don't talk men don't hold accountability
so right you know what another
definition of a real man is someone
that's able to express their emotions
but why are men not expressing you know
why you're not meeting real men men
all you've said is that you've not met a
real man like men
no i mean by and large you're right men
and women by and large you're right men
and women are different so like women
talk more than men but men don't need to
talk as much as women like a lot of
times women try to make men into women
but that's not how they are that's not
how they're wired you know what they're
not they don't men are fixers so if
there's a problem they go fix it where
women just whine about it for years and
years and years right so you what what
you're essentially asking men to do is
to become women
right
because women are women communicate in a
way that men don't communicate right so
if you get a man that communicates like
a woman what happens
generally yeah is you don't find that
man respectable because he now moves
like a woman
he's moving like your girlfriend he's
acting like your girlfriend he's not
acting like a man so what a lot of the
time men are told
be more in touch with your emotions
yeah by women they're told you know be
more um emotional you can cry in front
of me and as soon as that man does that
the woman's vagina dries up yeah and she
no longer finds him attractive and she
finds
that that he done to use that as an
excuse when they're in an argument to
use that against him so i don't so my
whole thing is this whole
new generation of women that are asking
men to be more emotional
are now asking men to be like women and
then use it against them when they do
become emotional no no can i i think i
think she wanted to say something go
ahead so you see how he said that women
women lack the ability to self-reflect
you see how you just
switched it to
the men being the issue instead of
actually deep in there you go what he
said
i say things in my chest so i can self
when you've come across women that's
made a point and then you
immediately went to say yeah about boys
did you get it i guess that's exactly
what it is that's a typical
and then they just completely switched
the topic yeah
you guys can't do that sorry go on you
were saying for me i feel like
self-reflection has been something
that's been really big on me this year
and i had a moment where i've not spoken
to i didn't speak to men for a good five
six months and in that time i was
thinking to myself what is the problem
because i was that girl who was saying
men not a problem this is the problem
today but then i'm like wait hold on a
second why am i not spotting the
patterns i'm going through the same
thing
every single time why am i not spotting
the patterns so it got to a point where
i just stopped talking to people and i
said to myself not that i was looking
for the perfect man but it will get to
the point where i
meet someone and i know that they're the
right person because
for me it's that i can hold myself
accountable and realize that i will spot
a red flag in a man
in the early stages but because i like
him and i'm hindered by the fact that i
like him i'll dismiss it and i'll just
pretend it's not happening and then when
it actually happens something big
happens i'm like oh my god are you maybe
attracted to red flags i i hope not not
anymore anyway i hope myself
i think most women like red flags i
think i think girls like to be cheated
on no not for me
sex is hard to get for men you know one
out of three men haven't did you know
one out of three men haven't had sex in
the past year or are virgins
so one out of three so that means
there's an entire pool of men that will
not cheat on you
um you don't wanna women don't go for
those yeah right
they go for the guys
literally they go for the guys that they
want right but then the problem is loads
of other girls want that same guy too
yeah well that's what we're going to do
one guy has bear options
that's women attract women are attracted
to men who attract women that's it so if
a man walked in this room right now
right and he was this geeky guy that you
knew wasn't going to attract women women
would be attracted to him but
if some adonis just walked in the room
like chiseled like ultimately oh my god
right so so women are attracted to men
that other women find attractive yeah
can i say like i think as well it's not
always about nice guy bad boy type of
thing
i think a lot of the nice guys don't
have confidence and confidence when you
don't have confidence
girls don't want you because
what's special about you they want to
look at someone who they can look up to
and a lot of nice guys have no
confidence they'll do everything the
girl says they don't want that the
problem is a lot of girls look at the
bad boy because he's got a lot of
confidence yes and he'll have a horrible
character and he'll cheat on you they're
like oh my gosh why is he cheating on me
but
they still stay because he's the most
confident guy they know right
the quote unquote bad boys have
developed that character over the like
years of their life of having girls come
at them yes let me say something about
the the confidence that he was talking
about right i think that girls
don't necessarily look for certain
qualities like you were saying right all
of these um things on the list that you
want
i'm not gonna i think it's just that
barrier that you put up
because if a guy walked in
if a guy walked in right and he was none
of those things that he wanted right but
he had his life together his morals
intact and basically he was heading the
right direction
i think he wouldn't really care about
whether he's in touch with his feelings
or not because i think men can learn how
to do that but it's the basic things
that are important like their morals
what they want out of life and stuff
like that i also think like it's in
evolutionary psychology that men and
women are attracted to certain things
like as women we want a man who
has good money and is in like a high
power position job because back in the
times where we were literally like
hunter-gatherers that wasn't that was a
symbol of the fact that he had a tribe
and he was high status
yeah yeah so nowadays that translates
onto a guy who's rich
and you know he's six foot he's muscular
because that means that he can protect
her
right yeah no there are biological
reasons for the reasons for the reasons
why we like what we like it's a lot of
it's biological i think this society
tries to erase the fact that we're
biological beings and act like like
there's a reason why men are attracted
to certain types of women because it's
biological can i i have a question for
the panel so i want everyone to go
around and say two negative traits
that your ex would say you have yeah
all right this is a super chat shout out
oh yeah yeah go ahead
um absent
in terms of
just being too busy
and not being with it all the time
okay
he would say that i never listened to
him um and that i'm stupid
that i'm crazy and
and i don't accept my wrongs
kingdom head self-reflection damn what
would he say he would say um
what would he say i call i'm laughing
because i know what he'd say all right
sing on um
you just don't want to say it
no i don't want to do it because it's
that bad self-reflection is what we're
talking about
he would say that i'm hard to please
and that he would say
hard of hearing
hard of hearing
controlling and i've got too many
standards
you want to go sarah all right yeah okay
okay let's go over there
she'll say i joke too much
and uh
i think that's all i could say okay
not not not your axe only has one
complaint that you tell too many jokes
that's it you know what are you my talk
you guys still friends like what no you
still no um my toxic trick was when it
was a bit of a heated situation i'll
kind of drop a joke if she set it up
right so just okay yeah okay
do you say you just doubled okay go
ahead
on my side
i would say first one two rational
and maybe two perfectionists yeah okay
okay
stubborn
and
not serious
okay
i think my first ex-boyfriend would say
um yeah stubborn and
what's the other one i talk too much or
something
like that so
so listening to the women's answers in
the room would you say it's fair to say
that modern women have an issue with
submission
100 yeah yeah yeah yes yeah why yes why
i think that and like i don't personally
believe this but i used to be that woman
who felt like oh submission was the same
as obedience where the guy had all the
benefits and the girl was just a slave
but i think the reason why a lot of
women have a problem with it is because
of what we feel the word means like when
we when we look at the word submissive
we think it means being a slave and not
making any of your decisions even if you
don't agree with it and being at a guy's
back and call when like at least what i
learned is that's not what actually
that's not what submission actually
means
at least the way i see it being
submissive in like a healthy way in
relationships means that you trust your
man to make the decisions and it also
means you get to benefit from it too
because you get to be
free of making difficult decisions
and even and even like back back
piggybacking off that like running a
business i see how hard it is to make
decisions all the time it's very
stressful like honestly it's really nice
to just sit back and let someone else
make decisions yeah like i'd say like
with submission a lot of people need to
understand this so imagine like you're
running a business
the boss needs to be the person who
knows the most and knows what to do and
knows how to make the right decisions
and the workers are going to be
submissive because they have to follow
the lead because it's the best
the boss knows best
and
i think sometimes girls have problems
with being submissive to some people
because they don't think they're a good
enough leader but if they are a good
enough leader and the guys got
themselves together
then they'll be able to submit but of
course some girls wouldn't want to
submit anyway because they
just don't want to be in that position
of heartbreak linking back to what you
said right it well i'm moving back a
little bit but when you said what a real
man is i think
from what everyone said i think i've
formulated a good idea of what real man
is i think it's a man
who's the captain of his own ship and he
so you know i say submissive not
submissive in the sense like
he needs a woman who's willing to get on
the ship and let him steer it in the
right direction like like he was saying
about it's difficult to make decisions
you have to have a man that you respect
a man that you respect and the man that
you trust
to make those decisions and you know you
can give him advice and whatnot but he's
at the end of the the one steering the
ship
yeah see submissiveness as well yeah i
think a lot of it is to do with
if you've got a woman that's just like
their main focus is just to take care of
you and they don't want anything in
return they just want to make sure
you're good that's a submissive woman
problem is today is a lot of women want
stuff in return they'll be like oh i've
cooked for you all week why you're not
taking me to another coffee at the
weekend
and you get a lot of that in
relationships and it's very rare can i
ask a question
did
where people's fathers had do people
think that their fathers were real men
no yep hundred percent yeah
top g
because um i think a lot of the time
that
women say um
because i've had this happen to me a
woman said oh men are supposed to do x y
and z and it's because that's what her
father did do you know what i mean so i
think a lot of women see real men as the
men that they grew up with i.e their
fathers and i think there are a lot of
women out there
that grew up with no father so when they
say oh
a real man should do x it's like well
what do what would you know
do you know what i mean yeah girl girls
that don't have abs uh present fathers
growing up they're the ones that really
have the biggest issues in relationships
right 100 i think in order to be
submissive you also need to be at peace
like if you're submissive and
you
if you're not at peace if you don't
really speak into the mic a little bit
oh sorry if you like have your guard up
and you are constantly looking for
errors within that man then you're not
really
at peace you're letting past things
affect the way that you're viewing this
new man now in order to be i feel like a
lot of women worry that if they're
submissive and they completely let a
guard down to a man and then he
basically messes up or something they
feel some type of way that is basically
what happened to me with my ex i
completely dropped my guard down i was
submissive i was i was happy
and then when things went wrong i was a
complete meltdown but it's because for
me it was like
in a way when you say that the man's a
leader in a way it's like you can't kind
of lose that leader so you kind of lose
yourself in a way because you become one
you know what
you've done the wrong thing you've not
done the like you've done the right
thing you've just chose the wrong guy
but then it makes it hard for you to do
it again let me ask you when you're
going to struggle to find the right guy
if you didn't stop sorry
you said when things went wrong what
exactly went wrong like what was it i
went wrong well
disloyalty on whose part on his part
obviously so then give him that it's not
obvious nowadays it makes it like your
inability to pick a man or kind of see
through his act whatever besides he's
been on because obviously if you've
picked a man
who who's cheated on you how long were
you living for
about four years four years did he cheat
like multiple times was only one time
for my knowledge just once okay so
during this four years did you not see
any red flags that showed um
yeah and that's that's me and my
self-reflection you see the red flags
that's the point where you leave but
when you're when you're i feel like that
happens with women more women are more
likely to take a man back when they've
done something whereas men aren't um
with a woman we get blinded by love you
get blinded by love you take the person
back and then once you're completely i
think it's more than blinded by love
yeah cheating is different from men and
women yeah that doesn't mean
yeah like like men will have sex with a
hole in the wall that's why you got so
many no no seriously that's why you have
so many girls that are like fours fives
and sixes thinking they're eights nines
and tens because they're sleeping with
the guys that are eights ninths and tens
like modern women are side chicks and so
it's like like men will sleep down and
they don't they don't really care about
them where girls like
a man has to have a certain level of
requirements for you to sleep with him
like you're not sleeping with a guy
that's ugly broken fat but then what
makes it okay for men to cheat no i
never said okay i never said it's just
like it's not the way we're wired so
it's like yeah i agree like men can like
i said men can have sex of a holy mole
men can have sex with a girl who's a
foreign face
right and she might have a nice body
and just because
as crude as it may sound because it's a
hole he's going there if that makes
sense whereas women have like paul said
women have these requirements for men
most of the time if they're gonna
open their legs to a man and men doesn't
really have any that the requirements
aren't it's not a long list yeah i don't
care
a guy like your boyfriend probably still
loved you when he cheated on you yes i
mean it's but it's just for guys it's
just a physical act right you know it's
all star now that's all it is it's not
based on any emotion whereas women it's
all emotional
that's why you keep it more you deep it
more because you think right i cheated
that means i have to really like that
guy right so then you deep it thinking
ah he don't love me no more yeah really
he was just bare horn he couldn't
cultivate controversy
she was just like there yeah like have
you ever have you ever been cheated on
you realize you have to worry about the
ugly girls too yeah and you're like i
don't even think
you're comparing yourself in anything it
usually is always a more ugly girl yeah
she was just like available in there and
a lot of women do that they see a guy
that she's like you cheated with that
[ __ ]
she was here i was she was there
was saying you know it's like you got
steak at home but yeah that greasy
burger on a night out just really it
hits sometimes right that's the spot
in the morning that same donut like that
don't i mean there's gone like you don't
need this yeah you won't even eat it
look at that
what is exactly so i have a question for
the men what do you think a real woman
is
and can and can a fat chick be a real
woman yes yes i mean a real woman is
just a woman that's completely in touch
with a feminine side is a nurturer that
just wants to they look at like they
look at their man like their child kind
of thing like they just want to nurture
them look after them make sure they're
good
um
can't can a man be broke and be a real
man
yes if he's trying to get out of his
situation okay go ahead uh i think a
real woman a real woman is just someone
who tries to uplift herself and her man
uplifting her mind in the sense where
whatever goal she's trying to achieve
she's pushing him towards that direction
trying to help him and for herself
someone like she's got
you said can a fat girl be a real woman
yeah but if she's um
as long as again if she's trying to
achieve her goals of trying to lose
weight that's her discipline and
understanding of herself that's not
healthy she's happy with her body though
if she's happy with her body that's fine
but you know find another man who's also
happy with your body i don't think
weight defines a real woman though
i think you guys are more referring to
like the lack of integrity right between
what she says she wants and what she
actually does what she does with her
free time because anyone can work out
anyone can like work on their physique
all women need to be slim though a woman
could not sleep
a woman could just be fat yeah and then
just want another fat guy and they could
just be fat and happy i just i just
think
i just think if you're i just i just
think if you're obese you're not
feminine so you're not taking like part
of being feminine is taking care of your
body i agree yeah and so how are you
feminine you've got some sexy fat girls
though
gemma collins no no but it's more in the
way they carry themselves i think it's a
confidence thing because you've got some
some big women that they have like sex
appeal because they're so confident in
the way they are do you think do you
think that that line of thinking is
general or specific
it's very specific because right because
i'd say probably most overweight women
are going to be self-conscious and
they're not going to be not confident
but you do get some do you think most
men are attracted to that women
no right now yeah because i'm saying
like there's definitely exceptions i
think it's a confidence thing more yeah
more so would you say that would you say
the majority of fat girls are feminine
uh
i i see with like feminine you know i
wouldn't class it as like a weight thing
it's more of like you know
weight says a lot about person
but to me it's like weight says a lot
about your choices exactly yeah and so
if you're overweight you're making poor
choices and usually those choices don't
go with feminine behavior okay but if
like for a lot of african people you got
like you know the aunties might be like
big
but they're like the most feminine women
you know because they they they they
take care of the household it's an
exception
would you say it was so i'm sorry i
always i always forget to clarify but
i'm talking about the west
yeah i don't even still hate you i mean
okay okay
i think when it comes to femininity it's
about the confidence you carry yourself
with
so if you're overweight and you think
that you're going to be more attractive
your femininity is going to tell you to
try to be as attractive as possible so
you'll go to the gym but if you're not
confident in your obesity then
it shows you're not really feminine
because you're not really caring about
it but i think it's all a matter of how
much
how much you like your weight as it is
if you don't like it and you're just
saying oh yeah i love how my body just
because you don't want to go to the gym
it's a completely different sense but if
you love how you look
then it's a completely different thing
as well because you thought oh do you
wanna say something yeah okay just
because someone's confident doesn't mean
they're feminine like some people carry
a full sense of
confidence and um yeah femininity is
definitely about taking care of your
health and being
obese and overweight is not
healthy
i just i looked her up
do you know that
that little
that little experiment that you done
there goes to show that women see things
very differently from men
like so the fact that you would see her
like oh she's hot though and guys are
like hell no means you don't know how
guys think of like you don't know how
guys see women i don't think they can
hello i think being funny i thought you
said
can i just say something
i thought he said men would [ __ ] a hole
in the wall
yeah gemma collins is a no they would
but we're going by aesthetics
we're going back this just also it's
like if you showed someone a picture of
beyonce right and then you showed a
picture of i don't know some girl that
works at wherever the guy's gonna go
because men are visual creatures
someone is smashing that someone else
someone out there is smashing germa i'll
give you i'll give you an example so
i've had guys on the show like say that
they're embarrassed of the girls that
they slept with and that it's just
better than their hand
so you know she might be better than
someone's hand
right but it's not it doesn't mean
that's who they want yeah but then
okay that's why they're not retaining
these kind of men because like some of
these guys in this room they might not
say it publicly but they might like
everything
every guy they're a drunken girl
every guy in here has had sex with a
woman
yeah that they know they wouldn't
want to generally be out with in public
yeah in fact
it's like he had sex with her but you
don't want to take her out to dinner and
stuff do you know what i mean can i ask
you a question of course so when you
were saying that um
with the whole gemma collins thing and
men are visual creatures and things like
that are you speaking as a majority yeah
generally like yeah
black white asian all men i think
generally men have a certain certain
things that they all kind of abide by so
like i said men generally
will have sex with anything if it's
presented to them but gemma collins no
one wants to just but most men but
generally
right but there's always exceptions but
i'm saying generally
they don't want to go out on the street
with gemma okay so can i be honest this
is my woman so a lot of
what i've seen so
well if i've walked up and down
tottenham i'm going to do up areas walk
up and down tottenham or do at west
london i've seen black men in particular
go out with women that look like gemma
collins and have babies with them and
hold their hands and i'll tell you now
carnival is next week
tell me how many men black men know what
it is they're man the truth let me
finish no no they're not trapped not
they're not
living in that household
they're not trapped they just don't have
nowhere else to live no but they i don't
know how happy they are
talking about an exception
no okay okay okay okay but you're saying
you're saying you said she he likes to
live with her because she has a house
no that's not what i'm what i'm
basically saying because he because he
said she's trapped but i don't know
i don't know
sorry guys
wait
sorry let me get my words together
because he said he's trapped i don't
necessarily think that's because he's
trapped but majority
from what i've seen from my day-to-day
when i've come across women that look
like gemma collins or whoever they have
been
they've been happily walking around with
their friends
understand that average people go
out with ever are supposed to go out of
average people yeah but you're basically
you don't you you're not talking about
like a higher value man walking around
with a gemini yeah like you're just
looking like it's the average tyrese or
whatever jason's not gonna pick gemma
collins but what makes sure you think
that gemma collins has not also got
herself a high value okay okay i'll tell
you why because look at look at the most
sought after men who's on their arm the
tom brady's of the world the leonardo
dicaprio captain so the men the who leah
well he dates a girl under 25 he swaps
his girlfriend out every time
but and i'm saying like all the most
sought after men the nba players the nfl
players all those guys have trophy wives
that are thin they don't you don't see
them with whales
and you might you could you could name
the one exception out of the whole
league yeah i'm sure i'm sure every girl
has the butt but the one the one but but
you know by and large they're getting
hot chicks they're not they're not
they're not taking over they're not
taking a whale look at the footballers
over here look at their weight
a footballer wouldn't have a gemma
college
if a guy can't get the hot chicks he'll
settle for the whale but that's no guy's
first choice
and then don't bring up that one ever
all the girls always bring up there's
that one thing in africa that one town
it's just like oh there's that one
person orders that one celebrity that
does have a fat wife but it's like
generally yeah but this is this is
reminding me of that conversation
everybody's having online about men
being emotionally attracted to other men
than women it's making me think like do
you think men
what
do you think that men are actually not
attracted to these women or they're more
they're more worried about what their
boys or what other people's perception
is going to be of them being with that
woman
partially they don't no guy wants to be
embarrassed by his chick you're a
representation of him so if you're like
if you're if you're fat and you don't
look good enough to be taken in public
it's it's because he's embarrassed to be
with you he might you might be good
enough to sleep with but he doesn't want
to be seen with you i think men care a
lot about status so like when they're
choosing a girl they also have to think
about how is this going to make me look
in terms of my reputation
every guy likes having a pretty girl on
his arm yeah i mean when you're walking
down the street and other guys are
checking out your girl it makes a man
feel good yeah i think i think as well
as the respect of it like if you've if
you're rich and you have a bad card
people are gonna say oh maybe he's broke
or something like that and
as a man you want to be respected by
other people
and
having a woman who isn't as attractive
as you think she should be
people might not respect you as much and
as secure as a man can be they will be
insecure that maybe this person might
not be at my level
plus
women want that guy that other men
respect see
if a man walks into a room
and all the men go towards that man like
yo what's up man women are looking at
that guy who's that guy like who's that
guy that all the men are giving that
respect to you so
like you got also you know put that so
when and also
a lot of the time is the woman that he's
with so if he walks into the room with a
certain type of woman
everyone was looking at him like or even
the guys are looking at him like yo that
guy bagged her
back down demand a certain level of
respect yeah beautiful woman on your
side because it's not easy yeah that's
what men respect i respect the fact that
they know that begging that girl is
definitely not easy so well done to you
right and and men give each other that
silence acknowledgement like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i have a question for the women um does
your submission cost a certain amount of
money
so so if does a guy have to make a
certain amount of money in order for you
to submit
yes or no like i don't think there's a
hard number but i think that the money
that a guy makes is like a
representation of his values that i
would submit to so like if a guy makes a
lot of money then i know for a fact that
he works hard he's disciplined he's
going somewhere in life i think it's
that trick that i'd submit to but that
said i think he definitely has to make
more than me okay roughly could you if
you don't want it it's okay uh he has to
make
multiple six figures
multiple six figures a month
but she's got she's got her man so yeah
she
found it okay good good job go ahead you
know
for me it wouldn't really have to be
finances more it would more have to do
with um intelligence if i am able to
meet i consider myself to be an
intelligent woman so if i was to meet a
man who makes who can educate me and who
makes me feel a bit dumb because i feel
like when i've dated i've always felt
like i am the more intelligent one and
i'm teaching a man things and i've to
meet a man who can teach me things is
something that i would find attractive
and something that i would would make me
submissive
he's teaching you things but makes 20
000 pounds a year
um
there's a number come on say the number
what's the number what's the number if i
believe his knowledge can bring him to
because i'm 23. i'm taking people within
okay
no no let's say he's making this forever
not not temporary this doesn't build a
man right
well
it's it's a difficult one you see let's
just need to make a certain amount okay
what's that what's the number
girls never want to answer the question
but i think
50k 50.
okay
um i'm not 100 sure
give me a rich man and we'll find out
okay but what's what's the minimum that
he needs to be earned yes for your
submission for my submission
what me cook clean do everything for a
woman yes no he makes all the decisions
if he said hey quit your job tomorrow
you're doing it oh yeah that's
submission right honey um how much um to
do my okay cool i would say
a good uh 100k a year okay 100k what
about what about the girls over there
um with the cost of living at the moment
i'd say it's gonna have to be in that
region yeah hundreds of 100k six figures
six figures a month for a year
i meant to say multiple six figures a
year by the week oh that's okay okay go
ahead next
um for me
i can't put a figure on it because i
just like a certain lifestyle
okay
if you can get the livestream it costs a
certain amount to have the lifestyle
roughly roughly okay 50.
would you submit
yeah 40 would you submit 30 would you
submit yeah 20 would you submit
maybe what kind of luck
but you do know like 50k like the train
drivers tfl drivers because that's what
they're okay
as i said like as long as you can
accommodate our lifestyle
i don't actually want to know what what
his salary actually i also think kind of
lifestyle you want though
what kind of lifestyle do you want just
based on a number
like there's so many factors that come
into play that i'm not i'm not saying
it's only a number i'm saying what's the
bare minimum that's my question like
everyone has a bottom floor yeah right
so i'm not i'm not saying
like that you couldn't date someone
outside of it i'm saying what's the
minimum
so
so roughly 30 000 yeah okay
so do you know what percent of men make
a hundred thousand or more
probably like less than ten percent
less than ten
i'd say the same
in here no no in in london
oh um oh i'm not too sure
so it's less than ten percent do you
guys think you're in the top ten percent
of women
there you go ten percent and ten percent
what i personally do okay like i think
just to like not cut anyone off but i
think it's okay to have a high standard
so long as you also are the high
standard like i think where the problem
is is we have men and women saying like
oh raise your standards like have high
standards but they're they're not high
stand they're not the standard that they
set for their man for the women so like
that's where i see that issue is like
there is an entitlement where everyone
wants everyone says they have high
standards but very few people actually
have the actions to like be the standard
themselves do you think that
that happens more than men or women
definitely i think women are more
um vocal and open about the fact that
they have high standards because i think
there's a difference in men and women
where growing up men were challenged and
they were told that they're not good
enough so they're already in that
mindset where they have to work hard and
get to the top right whereas for women
especially nowadays in society they're
told like oh you're fine the way you are
you're perfect and you know the men are
men
are you sure that's what's going on with
women right now that we're told we're
fine the way we are yeah i think you
don't you don't go on instagram and
every single ad is go get a boob job get
a bbl look like this look like that lip
fill is this you don't think that's
what's going on right who tells you that
men are women
society society women tell you that
society men don't tell you
men most men most men don't like that
stuff exactly because most men would
never tell them
i was touching on her point where she
said about what was your point you said
about women i think that nowadays women
more and more are told that they're fine
and they're perfect the way they are so
i'm touching on that point and who tells
me that she's right though no but she's
wrong because the rise in body
positivity yeah like nowadays we see way
more diverse models we're even being
told that obesity is okay and it's
starting to be celebrated i miss the
models that made me feel slightly bad
about myself bring them back but what
i'm saying is women women tell women
this yeah men are not out here saying be
fat and it's great like men are not
telling women that men are not saying
get a boob job men are not saying get
get a bbl
generally like there might be some men
women are the ones um doing vlogs about
their bbl they're telling other women uh
what the pitfalls and the downfalls and
and the pros and the cons of are to get
a bbl so it's women pushing this type of
narrative to other women men are not
pushing this narrative and personally i
think like men are even reinforcing that
women are okay as they are because sims
are going for everyone like no one's
saying if they're going for everyone
like no matter how they look if they're
not attractive
they'll still go for it and it's letting
women believe that everything they're
okay just as they are
so i have a question for you who would
you say is an example of a girl that's a
nine on a scale of one to ten
[Music]
i don't have a specific name but are you
referring just on looks yeah like
everything looks does it start with men
it starts with looks okay i would say
someone like megan fox is a nine okay
would you put yourself on the level of
megan fox no so then you wouldn't be in
the top ten percent of girls
that's fair okay go ahead
do you think you're in the top 10
percent of women um
i know i don't think so no okay go ahead
you do i think uh cause you guys were
the ones that said because you said a
hundred grand why why so any questions
my question is
okay so
my question my question is why why why
do women that aren't in the top 10
demand men that are in the top 10 in
order to
why do women not not in the top 10
percent demand men on the top 10 in
order to submit why can't the average
man get submission
because i think for me when we're
talking about percentages in a woman
it's not so cut and dry where it's just
about looks i think there's a difference
between being good looking and being
attractive to men like being good
looking is someone who's got physical
beauty but a woman who's attractive has
the whole package like she's feminine
she's willing to submit yeah she's she
might not be you know the prettiest like
she might maybe be a seven or a six but
she makes up for it in substance or
emotional connection and so like overall
she might be a nine mm-hmm can i say
something about that just go ahead yeah
so i think what she's saying right in
the best way possible is looks obtain
and then the attractiveness retains the
man basically
yeah i think and that's why so many
women say oh like i'm not pretty i'm
doomed or i'm gonna be single i think
that looks can get the guy's attention
but it's personality and substance
that's gonna convert him to seeing you
from just a sex object
i'd say this
guys can get the guys that get sex they
can get sex anywhere right they can get
sex on an app they can get sex when they
go to a bar they can get sex there's a
certain level of men those top 20 of men
women are so seeking these guys so those
guys have a lot of women to choose from
the question now becomes from the women
who the guy actually chooses
what are you doing to differentiate
yourself from those other women that
that are just
available
yeah and it's definitely not just going
to be looks because a man of quality
like if a man
if he's got high standards he's probably
the kind of man who works on himself he
wants a woman with the same mindset you
think leonardo dicaprio would he
not be a man of quality
i don't know enough about him to comment
he doesn't date women over the age of
25.
okay i think after 25 you're on sale and
he's like what age like 40 yeah
he he's like 40 something 50. i don't
know if you say this what i mean it's
just if you look at all the girlfriends
that he's dated they made a chart and
it's like every time they turn 25 he's
like
22
21 but i don't think that makes him low
quality i think that's just to a man's
preference yeah i think he's called
adoptions as well and so like a lot of
times like we'll try to shame men if
they just want to date for looks but
like that's most of what men like no
guy's dating a girl he's not attracted
to i think that's just but what if we
look at someone like jeff bezos
isn't his wife like not conventionally
attractive
to the divorce they've been together
oh she's at least not the typical like
super trophy correct you you see that
but they typically get them young
so like if if a girl
if that like usually like when she
started dating jeff bezos he wasn't jeff
bezos yeah and then he got to a certain
level started cheating on her and she
was like i'm not with that and laughed
she got good from the divorce and maybe
in like the context of relationships
leonardo dicaprio might not be a man of
quality like we know that he's got a
high net worth
but being a hot you know high value man
isn't just to do with high income it's
the other things too so if he's been
married and divorced multiple times
isn't he the common denominator like
doesn't that show that he's got self
work to do too when it comes to
relationships i don't think he's ever
been married actually okay but i just
don't i don't think we should shame men
for wanting what they want so if a guy
if a guy wants to date a girl just on
looks a good loan i say go do it
can i we should shame women amen i think
if a man because a man has to become
something to earn that women are just
exists
so women something to earn that as well
no no no if you're okay and if you're if
you're if you're here if you're all you
have to do if you're a hot 18 year old
you just have to not get fat and not
sleep with the whole football team and
you can get on a yacht with a
billionaire it's very true that's it
that's all you have to do where men have
to get money they have to be muscles
they have to get game and they have to
get framed and they have to learn this
stuff so in order for a guy to get if he
works his whole life to get girls and he
just wants a baddie that he can take on
a boat he worked his whole life to get
there how am i going to shave him for
that women you just had to exist there
are women in dubai on boats from the uk
that like he said were just pretty yeah
right and they're now on the boats yeah
but guys but they ain't got a penny but
the guys that they're on the boats in
dubai with had to put in so much work to
just get that vote not all of them you
know what i'm saying do people not have
no generational wealth the people's
parents not have money that we put yeah
yeah do what you're right
dubai is a family trip spot
like like there's no families going to
dubai it's instagram models
no i mean as in these men these men that
you're saying they always all men work
so hard for this money no watch it
generally they're not generally they've
got money from their parents and it's
the majority in the us the majority it's
like 80 of millionaires or i think it's
88 of millionaires are self-made yeah so
not not typically the typical
millionaire and the typical billionaire
made it themselves generally speaking a
man has to create his own value yes
whereas a beautiful woman is just has
that intrinsic value just by being there
like literally like i could drive past a
beautiful girl at a bus stop and still
like be like ra i'm gonna chat to it you
know what i mean whereas if a guy is
sitting at the bus stop no matter what
you look like the girl driving past
ain't looking at you the same
but you know what i mean can i ask you
but a lot of times a lot of times we'll
like shame men for wanting what they
want so like it's just i'm not gonna say
he's less valuable of a guy just because
he wants to date 22 year olds or maybe
he looks at looks first
i think like overall it's the value
comes from the money and if you're the
rare person who has the money you get to
you get your say and it's unfair of
course but
if you're valuable you get your say
that's how the world works and
some people like to try and change it
but that's just how the world works and
we have to play the game as it is i also
think like in practice though if we look
at let's uh let's count the exceptions
out like celebrities or high-profile
people
i just
i feel like if a man is of quality then
just in practice doesn't he look for
more than just looks like does he not
want a woman who has substance of course
well of course because you can get that
which i mean
so like you go for a load of beautiful
women but then it gets to a point where
it's like okay you need to provide
something more than that something more
i'm not saying i'm not saying they don't
look for that but i'm saying it doesn't
make him low quality if he doesn't
right you know what i'm saying like it's
it's the verbiage it's like you're
implying that he's low quality if he
doesn't look for that the thing is a lot
of women see
guys with trophy wives on their arm
right and they think that that guy just
chose that woman just because of her
looks now while she may be pretty that
woman's doing things for him
that most of the women that were in his
life are not doing
do you know what i mean and that's what
a guy generally because i said he could
have pretty woman after pretty woman
after pretty woman
she's different whoever she is she's
different she's she's ticked a box that
those other pretty women did not ticks
yeah and that's why i think like the way
to differentiate at least as a woman
isn't just by looking better it's by
doing the inner work right because i
think um we have this mindset where if
we don't have good looks we're doomed
but i think that's a bit of a cop-out to
escape doing the work that actually
counts which is like
you know healing yourself or working
through past traumas or whatever it is
you can't you can't work
but you can't work your like you have to
have a looks floor
like the if you want to go with the top
10 20 of guys you have to be at a
certain level and if you're not at that
level you're probably [ __ ] out of luck
like you're not you're not getting that
what's that level
what what do you mean what's that level
that they're looking for that if it's
top 10 percent guy i'd say you'd have to
at least be a six seven to get a top per
10 guy like
if you're overweight cooked looks wise
like there's a lot that a woman can do
to elevate her looks like i think most
women if they learn how to dress
themselves or like if they know how to
dress to impress themselves then they
can probably make the cut for most men
right
and consistently do that though not just
like on a one-off
yeah you know i mean a man wants someone
who's looking good consistently yeah
yeah yeah
yeah like i think it definitely takes
effort but i guess my key point is that
you don't have to look like a supermodel
if you just put a little bit of effort
into the way you present yourself and
you do the inner work that can take you
a long way no i i agree with you but i'm
just saying there's a there's a floor
right in the fat chick scene in it yeah
generally and generally you hate that do
you want to read the super chat yeah
i'll read the super chats um give me one
sec guys like the video the like is the
most important
metric that youtube uses in order to
push out our video so like the video
also guys we have a new clips channel
and we hit 25 000 subscribers
on the clips channel um so everyone go
subscribe to that we want to get to 50k
in the next two weeks that's our goal
um okay so 90 free toe pie a girl are
girls attracted to poor guys but don't
date them because they don't want to be
embarrassed by their peers women don't
love only men love for you lb burke
circa
looks get you into the door your
personality gets your name on the
mailbox jacob mackenzie best hosts in
the manosphere goes to karen karen
samuels and sarah tomasi keep up the
great content
um vincent dallas isle pearl should drop
a fitness routine for all the whales as
a former whale herself getting getting
good job getting rid of your inner shamu
pearl we see those legs das token
excellent example of why men date
younger younger girls have a realistic
expectation these girls are single and
pending whom none of that none no one of
status brit cormier
he has to teach me things really that
answer is a joke you have to submit to
learn if you are not submissive you will
you will never learn you can hear it i
know more so he will not teach me
sentience to the girl who tells i who to
the girl who said ig tells women to get
a bbl and other enhancements is missing
a key fact ig's viewers are
predominantly women where youtube's
viewers are mostly men so women are
reinforcing the the beauty standards in
an echo chamber called ig
justin morrison please comment on this
observation the dating and marriage
problems are concentrated in the metro
i'm from a smaller ag lots of two-parent
households and happy marriages agree are
your non-city friends happier and why
vincent dollisale she really thinks
football players want to come home from
practice practice to see another
linebacker
manny f
how do you guys think until the body
positivity warriors will turn on lizzo
just like they did on adele when she
lost weight
the savvy ninjas
the one thing men lack is emotional
intelligence high eq enables men to be
honest at the same time and deliver in a
loving way keep it vincent dallas out
chick on the left of the couch is toxic
she wants a gf not a bf we will send a
supply of purinas in her future the uk
economist please ask your guest for
marriage what type of men do you think
qualify for including his income the
true kali roy
five dollar super chat thank you um red
ready mean green smash the like but like
button folks secondhand knowledge isn't
what you're looking for but the topic
makes people think
fast scar men should walk away and build
leave these women to the utopia that
they wished for you are watching why
marriage is dead vincent dallas out girl
in the girl in the kitchen in the
all-black clothes and girl in the middle
of the couch are feeding off each
other's delusion loud and wrong dubman
pearl asked the panel what do you think
dating is like for the opposite sex
manny f to the women do you prefer an
agreeable man or a disagreeable man matt
butcher if if i have learned anything is
that most women thrive on drama if a man
doesn't provide it the women will willis
um i feel that men want us to be more
emotional because that makes us closer
to what they are like my testosterone
said no thanks chris with the 100 super
chat
[Music]
okay um i have a st
i have a stable of side chicks that i
lie to every day in order to keep them
around it is extremely exhausting i just
wanted to say thank you to the ladies on
the panel for arguing with reality you
are helping us rich guys pump and dump
these 304s on birth control will
sorry willis boy boykins women want us
to sit around and whine about our
problems i'd rather spend time on
solutions we aren't emotionally
compromised
tech spirit
most men definitely know how to chat
with other men we find it extremely hard
to chat with other women most times we
can't get our thoughts across without
blowback and heart emotion matt butcher
doors go to any labor job give 10 men
and 10 women blueprints to all materials
to this get the same house and see what
happens do the same with caring for
patients women are better dub men pearl
as the panel started
what are two negative traits someone has
oh i did that one that was a good
question vincent d'allisal a woman
saying i'm just working on myself most
of the time is in the streets and the
men don't want them dog mpa
men get a job at 16 and work until they
are dead that's our reality women think
they want all the smoke then they hit 35
and want to find a real man
christian when women gave got the right
to vote in the 1920s they voted for
warren g harding because he was good
looking and charismatic he's one of the
worst presidents in u.s history women
make decisions based on emotions if you
pander to women you win elections doug
mpa since women will not let a man say
what a will not let men say what a real
woman is then women should not have a
saying what a real man is you created
this ladies accept it
um i think that's all of them also guys
um
a quick announcement i forgot to do this
at the beginning of the show
tomorrow we're going to do a show and
then after that we're not having another
show until next wednesday so we're going
to go a week with off off of shows
because we're going to be moving and
trying to get the new studio ready and
that's just going to take time so quick
announcement there yeah go ahead all
righty we have some substitutes
yeah and we've got some new people on so
i guess we're just going to go around
and you guys can do the same thing we
done last time um except for oh they did
their intros remember
yeah yeah we went all the way around i
forgot yeah yeah no doubt fine all right
so we'll go into the next question um
it's a bit of a controversy well
sometimes maybe controversial um is up
do we have any fathers in here
that yeah
right
when it comes to manhood
can you really be a quote-unquote
real man
if you don't father any children
i don't think so because
i was saying at the beginning i'm a
single i'm single but i'm also a father
single father my little boy just turned
six months so
by default naturally i must work on
myself as a man as a father to increase
like how can i say that
the fatherhood for him
for my little boy because
we build naturally the next generations
so we need to get away about
the impact that we're going to leave the
legacy not only for our family
for the society
like are we going to leave our children
and make sure that they're going to be a
good person for themselves also at
school
in the future job etc so it's so much
important especially nowadays
to raise awareness
about
the question like what is a man because
like a few years ago like decades ago
the question about what is a real man
never exists but nowadays we ask the
question what is a real man because
being a real man embracing ourself
at the deepest level seems to be toxic
because we talk about toxic masculinity
so just embracing ourselves seems to be
toxic nowadays
and we are asking also the the the core
question where are the real men
that kind of being shut down by society
or by some movements
so it's our job our duty
as a man as a father
to make sure that we're gonna leave
a good mark and when i mean marx i mean
our next generation well the reason why
i asked that question is because when i
speak to a lot of women they reference
their father
as that quote-unquote real man so i'm
the reason why i'm asking is
do men who have children
leave that mark of being a real man on
children's eyes so can you actually be a
quote-unquote real man about a child
um to an extent because you can still
have a father and not be a real man like
you still have kids and not be around
i think you can i think there are a lot
of men who have children
accidentally
and it doesn't make them a real man it
just means that they accidentally had
children
but in the same vein there are a lot of
men who maybe choose not to start a
family but they check off the other
boxes of being a man
right
would you say um would you say george
washington was a real man
um
i don't know enough about him
he gets down too you don't know george w
k like you don't know about george
washington yeah fair fair enough i just
think like if someone's a great and
powerful man in history to the point
like they're talking about him hundreds
of years later he didn't have any kids
but
didn't he own slaves
what did he own slaves
george washington yeah he did yeah no
roman to me
i'm just saying he actually it's
actually interesting he um
he
had a different like he inherited his
slaves and it wasn't as simple as he
could have just like let them go because
um the debt that's incurred on them like
you can't just release them and so he
his slaves actually like he had a really
good relationship with them and they
considered him like a dad
oddly enough like a lot of his and all
of his inheritance went to his slaves i
mean i mean i hear that but i just can't
take a man seriously if you're only in
other people yeah do you know what i
mean that's just for me yeah no i mean
yeah it's just i think a lot of times
we'll like judge on the times
yeah and it's like he inherited them it
wasn't as simple like because a lot of
times they'll like take down the statues
and whatever but yeah
he couldn't just let them go because
they would be homeless at the time
yeah a lot of things yeah like it wasn't
yeah go ahead
um do you also think
another question sorry do you think men
of this generation have lost their
purpose
yep yes i think everyone has oh go on
expand on that
um
i just think
a lot of new problems have been created
people are
thinking like all these new genders and
all this new stuff that's come out is
taking our eye off
what life is really about
and
like down to the core like we're here to
reproduce
feed the earth and go on like we're not
here to
all this other stuff it's never it's not
going to matter
like if you
i don't know think you're this or you
think you're that it doesn't matter
like that's not what we're here for
i think that um
we've definitely lost our purpose and i
think it's due to
how
easy everything has started coming so
you don't need to
prove yourself you don't need to do
anything to get your
how should i say this
um
okay so men can be easily distracted
right
they can play games all day right
they'll enjoy themselves and
that's so fun everybody's so in love
with the short-term gratification
that
they don't really care too much about
the long-term
um pleasures
like even if it comes to getting with a
woman or something like that
they don't need to work for it they can
just watch corn it's
it's right yeah like
we don't really have to work hard so
it's easy to just indulge in the
um quick pleasures right
it's easy to forget what's
important and they and later on in life
everybody tends to just
not really achieve much because they're
happy with the
short-term pleasures yeah i think like a
lot of men probably and women um they do
the bare minimum in their life just so
that they can get by and have fun when
they're not working
instead of pushing themselves to grow in
all areas of life um do you think men
have lost their purpose
i mean yeah definitely um
how can i say that
just at the the basic basic level
biology level nowadays we talk about
feminist movement et cetera that we're
all the same
um we're actually not even though we are
more
like
that we are different there is some
differences
but
and those differences
at the scale of a population create huge
gaps in different level sports our
choices um
school or
our relationships but the fact that we
want to remove those differences
both men and women just get lost
and the core are the basics
and it creates all those you know being
distracted um i don't know
so
yeah definitely with our self purpose
what do you think a man's purpose is
um
i mean yeah
that's the question about yeah like
what's a real man like what is
masculinity
head of the house
the way i see it he's got a mission and
a vision for himself like he knows that
he's meant for great things maybe it
started business maybe it's make an
impact at scale
but i think a man with purpose is a man
who's clear on what he wants in life in
terms of his career i feel like all men
are out like i feel like a real man is
just a man
like honestly what do you think the
purpose of a man like i think like it
doesn't mean he's a high value man yeah
but like i don't know you don't say is
she a real woman like i think oh like
it's just
what do you think the purpose of them is
i feel like because um
i think most men biologically
just want to be proud of themselves
and like so you just want to feel look
at yourself in the mirror like i'm
actually proud of who i am i've got this
amount of money i've got a good wife
i've got this i've got that i'm just
happy most people most men don't want to
look at themselves in the mirror and say
i'm a bomb i don't have anything going
for myself i don't have money i'm
struggling like you just i think
biologically most men just want to be
proud of themselves it doesn't mean that
you have to be like
the baddest man on the planet do you
think their purpose is to build
yeah i think um
i think some people don't see it as
something they have to do but
i think overall they just want to be
happy if building
the next generation is something then
that's their thing but overall they just
want to be happy because like you said
earlier like the whole like
the the way in which men indulge in
computer games
corn
all this kind of stuff to me says to me
says men have lost their purpose
because
go on go on
yeah because a man's
a man's um
a man with purpose would
generally
wouldn't spend most of these days
playing computer games it's because they
don't have women anymore
because again modern women are side
chicks so one out of every three men are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year if a man doesn't have like
women like they have nothing to work for
oh you're they're makers
it's on
yeah it's on we can a that's it i have
to join in i can't stay quiet but listen
i think a man's purpose is to create a
legacy to put it simply that we're here
to to create and do stuff so our man's
purpose is to create legacy but i think
in terms of the question have men lost
their purpose they have because the
order of society has changed society is
now becoming more general-centric so
it's become more female-led so now it's
becoming more female-led a lot of men
are now confused as to what their
purpose is right part of the reason for
that is because well one women are
breaking up homes so there's no meant to
guide the men of the new generation so
who's there to teach them is it going to
be women because women don't clearly
know so when women are telling the boys
oh we gotta do is be nice and buy her
flowers and then the girl looks at him
and says you're a waste man yeah it's
long so then that's where the men
start to become more problematic because
they don't know what it is to be a man
that's why i think someone like kevin
samuels was like the father to a lot of
fatherless men yes that's why his
platform grew to capacity so
we're starting to see now that as the
site becomes more female-led men have
now lost their way and that's having
negative impacts on society by and large
so that's part of the reason as to why
men lost their power the reason one of
the reasons why i asked this question is
because we have a huge movement now
where they call it lbgtq right and
basically men are now opting out of
manhood generally they're saying you
know what i don't want to be a man no
more i can be a woman
and
when that happens that says to me
that men don't
don't even want to be themselves anymore
and the reason why i believe so
that they don't want to be themselves
anymore is because they've been told for
four decades that their manhood is toxic
it's patriarchal um it's bad you're not
allowed to be a man you're a misogynist
if you if you actually expel all of this
male energy and so men
getting that message
for four decades whether subconsciously
or consciously i've said you know what
well i'll be a 45 year old man i've been
a man all my life and i'll say
i'm a woman now
do you know what i mean and so a lot of
men even young boys now you know i mean
it's happening with young boys young
boys are now opt-in to be women and so
it's like is manhood that bad well
what's the reason for that i think
people also are like coming out of it
way more because it's so much much more
widely accepted now
like it's almost
the norm with lgbtq and things around
that where before it was really really
frowned upon and judged whereas now it's
become more normalized so that more
people are willing to
be open about it well i think i think
life is harder for men than women
so i think women live life on easy mode
till they hit like 45.
we just have no idea because like you
don't i don't think most girls
appreciate how privileged we are as
being a pretty attractive young girl
right where men have to hit reality hard
so that's why you see so many
that's why you see so many like men
transitioning to be women go ahead can i
just add you to answer like one of the
previous questions um i feel like
society has steered so much away from
nature so there's a lot of technology
and a lot of
inverted
natural energy so i feel like men don't
want to be men women don't want to be
women and yeah it's just all the
shambles
at the minute just to touch on your
point just there that you said that
women are privileged for being pretty
and you've got an easy life till you're
45.
what about all the people that have been
essayed and all the things that have
happened to them in their life is that a
privilege that's an exception it's not
the rule is it an exception or is it
does it happen
yeah i've had an essay yeah 100
the majority the majority of women have
asked of you if you want to ask the
people here on the panel ask the people
here on the panel are you saying this
happened to you percent right did you
press charges yes i did did you win
i'm in the process of it right now okay
that's good that's good but i'm saying
that's not the majority
it's not it's not like the one out of
they used to like tout this statistic
that was like one out of four women have
been assayed but that wasn't true they
were including like if you got your butt
grabbed at a bar that doesn't
a lot of it goes unreported as well how
do you know
like is that your view on men no that's
nice
but i'm saying i'm saying because if
you're saying that's happening you're
implying that most men are doing it no
it's not most men that are doing it but
it doesn't just because it happens to
most women doesn't mean most men are
doing it because men so the people that
are doing it are serial offenses
right so you're saying there's a lot of
men i guess let's say
i'm going to throw out a number so let's
say 30 of men
are
essaying yeah 80 of women well and why
and why would you and why do you just
believe women like if they don't report
it and they don't press charges like why
would you assume they're telling the
truth why would you lie because why
would you women
look at amber heard women do it all the
time
women like women and it's not fair to
men that they can like a girl can just
tell a story that someone did something
to them with no evidence yeah don't talk
about high profile men that they're
talking about are like high profile men
and they have they have a right a motive
to get something
as the average woman we don't have
anything to get from it
so imagine how many men it happened to
you for it to become such a hypothetical
i've had guys on i've had guys on my
show come forward and say that they had
a girl lying about them around campus
because she hooked up with them and she
didn't want to look like a like uh i
don't i don't want to say that
yeah yeah and it's like you can't just
assume women are telling the truth
because they're women like and why like
so they're so so so that's what i'm
saying so if they haven't pressed
charges and won
and the majority of women haven't done
that i'm not going to say that the
majority of women have been sexual how
many cases how many cases make it to
court
how many people even get their story
heard even when they've got evidence
there they go into the police with their
evidence generally if you if you have if
you have evidence they back you up
yes they
if you if you have evidence that a guy
sexually assaulted you the the law is on
your side as a woman
yes yes yes it hasn't it hasn't gone
anywhere like there's someone if you if
you have evidence and it didn't it
didn't and then do you know what happens
though if it happens to multiple women
then multiple women will come forward
and then he gets caught eventually if it
happens once it should be enough i think
because you need evidence do you think
do you think it's fair do you think it's
fair to men that anyone can just make up
a story about them and go to the police
right so you would agree you would agree
that you need evidence to convict
somebody and you can't just and do you
think it's fair do you think it's fair
that any girl can tell a story about a
guy and just say oh he did that to me
and we just automatically believe them
no because that was a hashtag like if
that was your brother if that was your
if that was your brother if that was
women if that was guys you stopped
interrupting me if that was if that was
your brother if that was your father
like you wouldn't be cool with that so
so when you say the majority of women
have been sexually assaulted and the
evidence isn't there you're making an
assumption that women are telling the
truth and that's not fair to men and you
women know women tell stories like this
is a thing women know that women can
exaggerate a story they can tell a story
to make themselves look like and feel
like the victim we spoke about it
earlier on that women are very good
victims they know how to tell a story
and a man who is not as
vocal in what happened doesn't men don't
want to be victims i know so many men
there's so many i know a few men that
have been victims of their own essay by
women but they don't speak about it
right 100 because men don't speak about
it and the thing is if that happened to
a man with money status and power who is
more powerful and who has more status
than johnny frick and deb what happens
to the average man that is giving an
incredible amount of power to women and
batshit crazy women that will get away
with it yeah and and so but you're it's
like you're contributing to it by saying
oh the majority of women have been
sexually assaulted if the evidence isn't
there we can't just blindly believe that
how are you saying the evidence isn't
there because if you look at the
statistics of the women that reported a
sexual assault to the police it is not
that the majority of women have been
sexually assaulted if you say the
majority that's above 50 percent yes
that's about 50 percent of women school
girls i'm telling you every every single
school girl what data do you have
from me being in school from me speaking
to everybody no no no no no data what
data what evidence do you have like were
you there when it happened
were you there were you there when the
uh when the grape happened
no i'm speaking about seeing things
myself
okay
were you there
yeah what when when girls were getting
approached by pedophiles when we were in
school you not approached i said grape
or essayed were you yeah were you there
were you there to see them get essayed
maybe on one occasion
right well that's can i say so
i'm not saying and i'm not saying that
you're lying right i'm i'm that i don't
i want you to understand i'm not saying
you're lying but what i'm saying is we
live in an evidence-based world anyone
can go around and say anything about
anyone right i can say that you before
we started filming you slapped me in my
face right but i'm going to need
evidence for it
people say a lot of things
what the what the world we live in is
that people can say a lot of things but
we just need evidence and and that's
what's
and you see it happening to average men
too yeah or girls will go on social
media say a sob story and then the
footage will come out like there is a
guy in um in a college in the united
states and the girl said that he graped
me the average guy no money no incentive
she said he graped me at the dorm and
there is video of her coming on to him
pulling him back to the dorm like like
forcing herself on him and she turned
around average chick
no no incentive so why would i just
believe anybody that doesn't have
evidence
we're not saying well me personally i'm
not saying to just be believe anyone but
when it comes to the whole pretty women
thing it's not all like glitz and glam
as you think like we do get harassed
unwantedly just because we're pretty and
people think that we should just accept
it because we're pretty like when you
say when you say harassed what does that
look like because because
this is a thing we spoke about in the
show certain women
will claim harassment right sorry and
certain women will claim oh it was
attention
i followed her does that make sense
followed home followed home no one
follows it if someone follows you home
that's harassment when you say no and
they don't take that no for an answer
that's not harassing me yeah i think
there's a whole person that's perfect
some women say they want a guy to chase
and they want to play hard together you
know what i mean it's like i don't know
where does the line get drawn okay if
you say no and he continues to pursue
you like like on the street is what
you're saying like you say i'm not
interested he continues and some guys
are just persistent that's not
harassment it is harassing that's a
that's a low bar sorry
i feel like what we're doing right now
is going with the minority and every
time and the minority being men it's
like earlier when we're talking about
fat women oh you're going to find that
one fat per that one guy who's with a
fat woman you know this is the same
situation you're going to find that one
man who was telling the truth but most
of the time it's women who tell the
truth now let me think about sexuality
sections
how did you know it's most of the time
you've been telling the truth
no no no no no no no can you i don't
know address that point yeah how do you
know that most of the time we're judging
you i'm dressing about evidence yeah
okay if it comes to police and evidence
they need cctv dna etc etc sexual
assault isn't always dna you don't or
you're not always going to have sperm
because it's not always a rape now when
it's great it's great
sorry sorry when someone sexually
assaults someone they're not going to do
it okay what is sexual assault let me
let me just define this first essay
sorry what is essay so essay is either
you're going to be graped maybe even
groped um it can even be
um taking off a condom without the
woman's consent
i say yes you need to be prosecuted for
that because that woman they call it
stealthing i believe yeah there's if you
were to go and look at the police
statement there's a whole load of wow
all considered that is a horrible that
is horrible for men if a guy a girl
can't so a girl can just claim you took
off the condom during sex and go to the
police yeah that's horrible for men it's
the thing where there's no camera in the
room it's either one person's word
against the other and you can't always
go to the men because then women are
never so can i say that as a man i've
been having sex with a woman and she's
asked me to take the condom off right
and i've said no so if i didn't if i
took the con or if she
took the condom off and said no no i
wouldn't do it is that now essay on my
part but correct those what i'm trying
to say
correct okay it can happen to men too so
she essayed me but this is the problem
they include everything in essay when i
like every advice
if you take off those cases are so low
you don't find cases like that often
because that woman is then trying to
prosecute that man for no reason most of
the time women don't go and say these
things for no reason if a woman does
that that is a small minority that wants
to get at that man for a particular
reason but most of the time a woman is
not going to go and lie for no reason
women are spiteful women women do i mean
women are spa do you know how many
stories i have of girls like taking
their not letting the dads see their
kids because they just have an issue
with the dad that's a common story that
happens all the time you have no idea
how far women will go because they hate
him just to feel like the victim just
yeah because like you said and there's
there's evolution behind it because if
you're if you're a victim historically
like more men will come to protect you
yeah there's like there's biological
reasons why women you can't do you can't
sit there and say oh women wouldn't lie
about this thing but listen women can
lie just like you as women know you can
lie and you can exaggerate stories and
you've got friends and family members
that you've listened to
heard stories from and you know they're
lying and you know they're exaggerating
so please but i think it's the same way
you find people who are sometimes a bit
tap sometimes a bit sick in the head
yeah and those are the minority you'll
find people who will do that but that is
not always how do you know it's a
minority that's the that's the like
okay but here's the thing we could go
back and forth about that he said he
said she said the women are saying this
the men are saying this because if i
talk to women they'll say everyone's
been essayed if i talk to men they'll
say all the men has been assayed but the
only thing we can go off of is evidence
that's it
and so if you're not willing if you're
not willing to if you're not if you're
not if you're not if you're not willing
to go off of evidence then we're just
going off of what you feel
so what does the evidence say about it
experience too but it's not it's not
it's not a majority of women it's a
minority of women and if you take off
the random things that they count for
essay when it's actual grape like
someone grabs you pulled like off the
street it's a very small percentage but
you see what you're saying you've you've
painted this picture of down a dark
alleyway grabbed off the street what
about the one with her husband and she
says no
can you not do that you can say no
no you can yes you can say no but you
see the picture that you painted of oh
you're getting you grabbed no no no no
what i'm saying it is not the same as
someone being grabbed off the street by
a stranger and grape is not the same
thing as someone taking off a condom i'm
sorry you could you can say that's
controversial but it's not the same
it's not that like someone being
traumatized by the people they're
different there's different things
but we put this all an essay which i
think it's just stupid and so then we
then we paint then we paint this picture
that women are being attacked all the
time by men when it's not true we're
more safe than we've ever been in all of
human history
how many how many women we are how many
women
all right
hang on hang on no hang on hang on the
reason why you're more safe than you've
ever been in history right
every single or generally the buildings
that are built that you live in
the cars that you are driving that you
drive
when you go to work it's all men that
are doing this stuff
men are actually making your life safer
and you totally negate it this building
the bricks that were laying were
probably laying by men the plumbing in
this building was probably done by men
men have made women's life so safe
to the point where women are now
thinking that they're so comfortable
that they can tell men you know what men
ain't [ __ ] well it's like well if men
ain't [ __ ]
go back and live in the woods throughout
throughout all of human throughout three
years
stop stop stop stop stop
throughout throughout all of human
history we needed a man to survive
now now you're able it's a privilege to
be able to live on your own as a woman
men had to tame the world they had to
build the buildings they had to make the
police forces all the people that
protect us are men
and it's like women
women are so unappreciative will still
go back and and say things like the
majority of women are being graped when
you know damn well that's not true
the majority of men the majority of men
have an innate
protection device within them
towards women and when you when i say
that i mean this police forces
armies
firemen
men protect society
because we're not just protecting
ourselves we're protecting the women and
the children but if they protect they
also they they can come across as
protecting society but they also take
that to their heads and think that they
can treat women any sort of way women
get groped or touched up in a taxi cab
where we're supposed to be safe getting
driven home women get touched on a train
like it for women to say oh it's sexual
her or sorry if you
say yeah yeah if it's essay i don't me
personally as a woman
i don't want to really go through that
kind of scenario and then have to go
when you obviously go to the police have
to then really go over those emotions
again it's not a whole listen i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna negate people's
experiences like that that is a very
unfortunate experience your experience
is very unfortunate and i'm not saying
that it's not
it's a good thing that it happens it's a
bad thing but i'm saying just to paint
the majority of men like you're okay
it's gross
no no okay
one at a time
what do you mean they're animals and
they want the majority of men aren't
doing that i'm sorry if you get groped
on a train you can call the police
that's a privilege that's a privilege
most women didn't have throughout all of
history and we are entitled sorry who
said it was the majority yeah
the majority you said the majority
of women
it's not and i said it's not most men at
all it's they'll be serial offenders
guys that think it's all right oh uh you
know what i mean i touched her bomb on
the train she didn't say anything so
next time he's gonna grab her down the
alleyway and next time it's gonna go to
this that's what happens that's why when
they catch
can i say
rapists or whatever
yeah yeah when they catch them they've
got how many people they've done what
they've done to it i'm sorry but grape
is very different than being grabbed on
a train one is lifetime traumatizing one
okay yeah but you can't you can't speak
about other people's experiences
different experiences affect people
different ways and i agree there's
definitely a lot of females who like
misreport or exaggerate but it still
doesn't take away from females who
actually get s aid and are traumatized
and i think men have as well a lot of
men have as well and that and that's
never ever been addressed a lot of men
have been essayed a lot of men
and i'm okay i'm speaking on my own
experiences of no men most of them lost
their virginity when they were 11 to a
girl that was like 16 or 17 or something
like that and that is a that is a like a
very common story that i hear and they
don't even realize what has happened to
them and i feel like that feeds into
part of the problem
i don't think the majority of women have
been graped
so that's that's fine that's your
brother
and i would i would say that's based off
of evidence and a lot of times like it's
always based off of what we feel instead
of based off of evidence
even if you go off of self-reported
surveys with no evidence it's still one
and four it's not the majority it's not
the majority and that's self-reported so
that includes women that make [ __ ] up go
ahead if we were to go off evidence five
years ago jeffrey epstein is just a
billionaire who is a lovely guy
people a lot of women when they get
essayed don't speak about it because
they feel like they're not going to be
listened to and they feel like they're
whatever they say is going to be
dismissed due to evidence especially if
you're a woman who's been graped and you
don't report it straight away you report
a year later or two years later you
don't have any you should you should
report it right away
i'm saying if something if something
happens to you you should report it
right right
like i'm saying why so you have the most
ladies
you can't go to the police and like i'm
sorry the best chance of getting
somebody convicted for something is
going and reporting it right away
straight
away
that's the best chance okay so let us as
men understand why it would take a year
because i don't know because i'm a man
so why would it take a year six months
to report something that just that
happened because
you might not be supported enough you
have to deal with that right yeah no one
else is dealing with that you have to
deal with that well that's the
difference between men and women because
men because men know and that's the
difference made between men and women
men know that if something happens we
gotta go report it straight away we
gotta go and do that straight away if
you're taking long i want women to
understand if you're taking long
and something's bad happened to you the
longer you wait the longer you're more
likely for it not to get like that's
just the consequence that comes with it
if you want to wait there's less likely
the guy's going to yeah
it's going to be
it might take that long rapists are
strategic with who they approach they
don't approach random women they go for
someone who they view to be weak and
someone who they view is easy to
approach those women who are then weak
are women who are going to be less
likely to go and report something just
like jeffrey epstein that's the example
i use he was graping young girls 15 16
somewhere even like 12 13. so when
you're at that age and he was convicted
yeah but he was convicted
he was convicted after a long time
because those women but that's what i'm
saying at some point the evidence comes
forward and people get caught if you
keep doing wild [ __ ] like that you're
going to get caught at some point
but but the problem is we consider it
like s-a where we're putting like a girl
getting grabbed her butt at the bars and
getting a condom taken off at the same
level as grape and it's just not the
same thing
and like and the thing is men
they don't care about when men get their
butt grabbed at the bar like there's a
youtube video sorry i had a woman pinch
my nose yeah they're like i this happens
all the time to man they don't say they
don't even happen all the time to men
where's that evidence
is that i say i'm in a bar a woman likes
me oh you're you're cute and she pinches
my nipple is that's essay well does it
bother you
no i was fine with it i was out with the
phone
considerate that the reason why it's not
so black and white is because the same
experience can affect people in
different ways but it has to be based on
what happens not everyone's feelings
it's based off of evidence and what
happened that's the great that's the
great area
yeah
and in the same vein just because
there's no evidence doesn't mean it
didn't happen like yeah but just because
there's not evidence doesn't mean that
it did happen either i believe i believe
do you know what i mean
that's the great area just because it's
not evidence doesn't mean it didn't
happen
no evidence doesn't mean that it did
happen so how do we
establish whether it happened or not
wait women take longer to report because
it's more likely they weren't even clear
if they were essayed in the first place
yeah that's true because it's such a
great area like if someone grabs my butt
i'd be like hmm does that is that really
serious enough to count as essay where i
would risk going to the police and you
know ruining my record i would just go
to another guy he's going to punch him
i'll say if you want if that's what you
want to do another theory in theory
definitely but it's one of those things
where when it happens to you for a lot
of women it can be shocking and you're
almost not sure what to do in that
situation
not really
i just i just go to another guy or a
brother
why would you go to another guy after
you've just been essayed why would you
do it if i got my butt grabbed at a bar
okay because who's going to protect me i
would go up to sarah i would go up to
sarah that's what i was who's going to
protect you when a guy is the one that
just broke you yes but i'm saying who
protects women generally the
men do who's more who's so why wouldn't
you go it could be your dad i don't i
don't know who you are it could be your
dad could be your brother you go to
another man to protect you who's more
likely to be protected in public if
they're in a fight men are women who's
more likely to be protected women women
right so by whom protected by who no no
protected from who men nobody who's out
here
right so men so men can be bad and men
can be actually men can be good too
right correct it's not all men are bad
but a lot of men are out here killing
people first off men are killing men
is that right or wrong men are killing
men and then on top of that men are
killing women as well look at what's
happening in london in the past three
years how many women have been killed in
london in the past three years but it
doesn't make sense to just
say okay
no but i'm not i'm not saying that look
the whole this whole podcast has been
around how [ __ ] women are and women are
all men's problems and oh women are so
sorry it's been about trying to
understand what a real man is we've
diverted but just because you get
triggered it doesn't mean i'm saying
that it's not about being triggered
every single no
all the comments yeah but all the
comments that you've said it's like oh
it's so great being a woman
it is it's not being prepared privilege
is invisible to those who have it
because you being a young woman you are
treated better in the world in general
you are you're different you're given
more opportunity
than men you're less likely to get
convicted of a crime than men like women
women women
men get four times the same sentencings
for the same crime as a woman
for the same crime do you think if you
murdered someone and i murdered someone
who is going to get the the longer
sentence yeah generally right right so
those are things women
women
women are more like
men are more likely to be victims of a
assault than women men are more likely
to be victims of a violent crime than
women men are more likely men are more
men are more likely to be homeless men
are more likely to commit suicide
like the world is hard for men
okay both men and women have different
hardships so i don't think we can really
compare yeah same
but i think there's different levels of
heart that will ultimately never
understand unless we are the opposite
gender i feel like i think women think
that their life is hard and it's really
not go ahead i think when it comes to
the highest of the highs
and less work and more reward i'd say
women could have it better of course we
can talk about the lows
and of course like
grape can be the lowest of lows but
overall
on an overall spectrum
i'd say women will have it easier get
together with someone easier to get a
job by flirting or getting let into
somewhere by flirting easier for girls
guys don't have as many benefits when it
comes to the lowest of the lows with
guys like let's just put into example
dating apps or something like that
guys are very lonely like i have a lot
of friends who
they're average looking they're cool
they've got a good personality but they
don't really get anywhere when it comes
to dating apps and then they go out to a
bar don't really get much either and
they're just lonely what do you think
that is
i feel like it's because the day in
market is definitely easier for girls
girls can get with anyone easily if a
girl wants to just
say who wants to get with me
there will be a thousand men lined up
right now fighting no no no people will
be fighting like no i'm going fast yeah
yeah but it depends talking about
relationships a hookup because i think
i'm i mean
i think if we can relate even
relationships
add nice guys to the equation because
we're saying it's hard for girls to get
relationship if a girl wants to go
for a relationship with a nice guy do
you think she's not gonna get of course
she's gonna get it but obviously they
want the guy the bad boys that are
confident and all this that know their
worth they know they can get other girls
those are the guys that aren't given an
easy relationship go to the nice guys
which is a good eighty percent probably
they're gonna all they're gonna be like
yeah please marry me right now
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year so
one out of three men is probably gonna
date you
one out of three that's a huge
percentage sorry you can keep yeah
okay okay
sorry did you want to say something no i
mean yeah in practice though the reason
why a lot of women are single is because
there's 80 of the women going for the
top 20 of men
because if a man
makes loads of money and he's got high
social status then the more money he
makes
the more money he makes the bigger his
dating pool is
whereas for a woman
the more career success she has the
smaller her dating pool becomes because
women only want to date up so then who's
the prize men are women
men
yeah i'd say it depends on who they're
going for if you go for the nice guy
of course the girl's the prize if you go
for the high earner the cool guy that
guy is the prize so are you saying that
average men to average men the prize is
the woman yes but to the high earner or
the high value man
uh they are the prize yeah okay did you
this is a super chat um texas female
teacher was just convicted of sexual
assault with a 14 year old student guess
how many days in prison she got
she hang on she assaulted yeah she she a
14 year old student yes how old was she
uh 35
how many days in prison did she she's
actually
she's got to be there for years
i'm guessing it's going to be like a
shockingly low number yeah she didn't
get anything is it like six months or
something
60 days
remember the only fans model in florida
that killed her boyfriend she's been
roaming for for four months would that
have happened if she was a dude nope
nope nope it wouldn't
it it really wouldn't yeah but these are
these are not like little races you see
what you said before about oh you're
gonna go pick that one guy that's got
the fat girlfriend that's what you're
doing right now like most women aren't
out here doing this
no no no
you're missing the point no no let me
let me address this you're missing the
point the point is that there are
systems in place to protect women where
there aren't those for men right that's
the point the point is there's privilege
in being a woman because the systems are
set up to protect us to the point we can
say oh he didn't wear a condom and he
graped me
or saved me yeah but i'm saying but for
men for men it's not the same she could
be convicted of that and get 60 days in
jail that that's the point it's the
system but most men get away with it
how do you know like what is the
statistical data when you say that like
this is the thing so you can't just say
anything
yeah like we want to know like
when i'm speaking i'm speaking about
personal experiences and my friends and
the people that i know around me
that's what i'm speaking so okay so when
your friends are being essay dear or the
people that you know around you like
pearl said before
were you there no i was not right so
what you have is a story
from a person that said x y and z
happened now my point is or our point is
everyone and anyone can tell a story
correct right but just because you tell
a story doesn't mean you're telling the
truth you could be telling the truth but
you could also be lying but so we have
to work on what we can prove
to move forward and and grape wasn't
even like men couldn't even press
charges for grape until a couple years
ago
like it wasn't even in the definition
that a man could get right right you get
great so i don't agree with that either
because the definition of it is
penetration by can i carry on you know
yes
yeah penis penetration yeah right which
to me
a woman
could rip could grape a man with what
how objects well
i'm just asking i'm not saying it can't
happen it happened before to a guy by
like three girls right okay
and that you can't you know i'm saying
maybe you might not think that's what
happened no no i'm not saying that it
can't happen or it won't happen i'm just
asking how does it happen
i don't know they pinned him down or
something not like
okay or i mean it's also like
going forward after he says no
right yeah but but you said that's being
persistent
no i'm saying
i'm talking about like during
like
like
the moment like during the moment if the
guy says yeah no no no i don't want to
like like i've had guys on the show say
they woke up and she was on top of him
yeah yeah after he'd said no that yeah
that can be considered essay really yeah
okay
yeah and even let's just say like you're
having sex
and then you take it out of a vagina and
you stick it in our ass and she says no
god damn what you doing girl would you
would you classify that as
that's classified as grape as well if
if you've consented to have sex and then
now he wants to like stick it in your
ass and you're saying no
that's classified as great i mean if if
you say no to something the guy does it
yeah that sounds like definitely
but those are like are those exceptions
to the rule order so and so after he
puts it in like then does he stop or
does he keep going no he's yeah like
he's not listening to what you've had
yeah if you say no then yeah i'm with it
like but then that's the same thing as
taking off a condom if you say no why
why does that change why does that
change the whole that equation
i just i don't think it's the same as
being graped being having a condom i
don't think it's the same as being great
let's just say he takes no let's just
say he takes it i think it's messed up
but i just don't think that's great if
he just takes off a condom no but it's
not it's not great obviously it's
classified as something else it's i
think there's different levels to essay
that that's that's a good q that's a
good um segue do you it's different
levels to
sex
well sorry i say
yeah but there is like in the lore and
stuff like that but i personally feel
like one thing could happen to someone
and it affects do you know i mean
everyone's yeah everyone's everyone's
affected differently right so then is it
based on the way you feel
what it is
you have to understand like sometimes
girls say no and change their minds and
so it's really confusing for guys
because before before this whole like me
too culture like
in pickup like if you look at the old
videos they'll just say like
if if a girl says no it's like a [ __ ]
test like she just want to be perceived
as a [ __ ] and if you push it a little
forward like she'll change her mind i
know that's like toxic nowadays and that
sounds really bad and it probably is but
on some level like girls change their
minds sometimes if the guy is persistent
otherwise guys wouldn't do it men need
to like themselves and sometimes and
sometimes it changes whether a guy
that you find is attractive or not
sometimes of women yeah but
that's just what i mean like sometimes i
have a question for the guys has a girl
ever told you no for sex and changed her
mind so many times for the guys i i just
would leave her alone you leave it alone
how she told me yes and then she said no
and then changed her mind later oh yeah
of course yeah and so it's like you have
to understand from the guy's perspective
it's confusing
because they'll say no means no but a
lot of girls change their lives but i
said sometimes that's part of the game
that women want to play to be chased
oh no don't do that oh my god no don't
isn't it better
a lot of guys do that now yeah like in
this generation like they're like oh
[ __ ] i'm not messing with this because
she might go back and forth
because you'll even have girls that like
like they had full complete like they
might have said no in the beginning he
pushed it a little bit then they hooked
up they'll she'll finish with it and
then be like oh well i said no with that
one time no no if you didn't kick him
out get no but sometimes no but you
can't say that because sometimes you're
not able to
at the whole day
men are bigger than you men like you
might be feeling like you don't want to
do something so that you don't get hit
or whatever else that's called a lot of
times pressure that's something you're
pressured into it that's not the same
thing and being graped if you finished
it and you weren't screaming and telling
him to stop like it's not the same some
of the time women will say you know what
this guy didn't even chase me like he
didn't even like
do what he was supposed to do and it's
like yo but if you said no and that guy
says you know what you said no fine i
won't do it but then you're saying now
and you go and tell your friends the
next day oh my god he didn't even try he
didn't even like try and push it so it's
like where is the line this isn't it
this guy's like where's the line for a
guy yeah i think this is where women
need to start taking accountability and
actually vocalize what they want right
yeah that you're confused within
yourself right now you're upset but but
some this is a thing it's a very weird
place because some of the time that is
part of the quote-unquote game that both
men and women like to play they both
like to play that i'm gonna catch you
you're gonna run
i'm gonna be a little bit more
aggressive you're gonna say no but i
know you really mean yes i'm like men
that have done that and women have done
they know that it's a very great area
it can be a very great area well and
there's no game to play if there's no
players
yeah everyone's everyone but like you
have to understand like from a guy's
perspective it's
confusing so if a girl says no and then
maybe he starts to do something and like
she goes along with it i don't that's
not great that's very confusing to a guy
you went along with it if you finished
and you weren't telling him to know stop
like you didn't keep saying that like
it's just not i'm just thinking from the
guy's perspective if a girl says no
isn't it better to just be safe and back
off
a lot of guys a lot of guys make that
conclusion now but it wasn't always that
way
it was like it wasn't like again this
isn't pick up youtube videos that used
to be on the internet where they would
say it's a [ __ ] test like girl's saying
no so she doesn't feel like a [ __ ]
yeah and i i also think like it's it's
both ways like on the girl i think women
also have to practice some level of like
sexual discipline so they're not saying
no when they kind of really want it but
that's the other 50 it's also on the guy
to know like when to stop pushing i
think it's it's a bit hard because like
usually for me
if i'm like oh were you on the internet
no then
i take that as
oh maybe you're playing a game but i'm
a smart man and i don't want to get
myself in trouble so i'll just walk away
and of course you can tell the tonality
and you can tell it's a joke but
not everybody's got the same understands
tonality like i do not everybody
is as smart as i am and
of course with different situations
people get into of course i'm not
excusing people who when someone says no
and then they keep on going and going
yeah yeah i think after a while you need
to kind of get the hint of course i'm
not going to come and defend guys who
are creeps but i think when it comes to
situations like that you should just
stop playing games if you want this you
should say you want it and you shouldn't
be doing that no
well and girls will will invite the guy
to their house have dinner with him get
half naked and then be like like you're
giving him every signal you want to have
sex
so
do you think that could maybe be
confusing for a guy of course it is
hundred percent so do you think
prostitutes can be great
yes yes of course
yeah of course i can yes
but i said but the
thing is guys are simple creatures and i
think we need to understand this guy's a
work of signals as like pearl was saying
you invite a guy to your house
you you're half naked in the house he's
thinking
okay something's gonna go down today and
then when you're like
no he's like uh what were those signals
he's like what was that all about so
that whole thing is like
you that's where women kind of have to
kind of take and i'm not saying any
woman deserves to be essayed or grape
that's not what i'm saying i'm saying
just take accountability for you know
the signals that you put that you put
out to guys a lot of the time so just be
aware of them that's all i'm saying and
to follow up on that that the amount of
youtube channel giving like dating
coaching for men
you can see on the comment and the the
amount of subscribers is is huge because
nowadays to avoid this kind of situation
they will make sure to get the knowledge
from experts to get an expertise so
for
when we were talking about the contacts
the girl giving signals etc all the
night drinking together being touchy and
the last minute exact last minute
going over at the home and she's saying
no so to avoid this kind of stuff they
go to this kind of channel to just
because it's so confusing the body
language because it's a matter of
tonality of voice you know somebody in
english from you but on our hand on our
point of view
even though like me personally
i get to know easily body language from
women when she's attractive with me or
not
but it's still confusing you know for
the average man
so
especially the average man who hasn't
dealt with a lot of women that's the
thing you know what i'm saying so the
more you deal with women the more you
kind of realize oh okay i get this game
i understand this do you know what i
mean but guys with no experience they
don't generally know and they could do
something to make the woman
uncomfortable she could say x y and z i
didn't like it he doesn't know someone
someone said girls practicing sexual
discipline you mean like how girls are
encouraging each other to have a 304
phase or a hot girl summer or how about
reddits on how to take advantage of guys
nothing about modern women show any
caliber of restraint as a matter of fact
i think we should read the super chats
yeah i got you okay yeah let's read the
super chat um guys like the video the
like is the most important metric that
youtube uses to push out the algorithm
so if you think this is an interesting
conversation you like the podcast please
like the video also subscribe to the
channel guys we're trying to hit 300k
it's crazy we just did the 24 hour live
stream i think we have 15 000 more subs
more so yeah then
yeah 265. we hit that today which is
crazy which is only a couple literally a
couple of days wow um also guys um
go subscribe to our clips channel and
like the video sign up for our
memberships if you want to see our
behind the scenes
first look at our new place that's under
the ten dollar tier so sign up for our
memberships okay
um brit cormier said this before but
i'll say it again regret is not essay
regret is just regret s-t-f-u-f-f-s
everyone knows no means yes and yes
means anal dragon stallion morning after
regret is not the same thing as essay
especially when you agreed to have sex
originally cry wolf much mikey omiki if
you're unattractive it's essay if it's
attractive if you're attractive it's
flirting dash token what about single
moms and their sons
david acts it's not that easy to answer
insert it in the ass
s-t-f-u-f-f-s
women are goats of finding
grooming or goats of finding the tiny
hill of trash blaze a ladies do you
think that if you were ladies do you
really think that if you were born a man
on your street
ladies do you really think that if you
were born a man your life would be
better just because and you'd feel safer
on the street men's lives are tough
03j kid a woman would protect them from
a freaking animal fire and even
themselves sometimes why is it that it
only has to be men protecting other men
james jackson um skullham jpt p walker
an american teacher raped her 10 year
old student for three years prosecuted
asked for 40 years she got 60 days jack
frost beat me to it lol chet grandy 351
i'd like to ask a question what can a
woman be held responsible for that's a
good question 90 free topaz can we call
in please i'll pay
actually we are really close to having a
call-in show so at some point maybe we
should add like call-ins to this yeah
definitely uh we're talking about doing
today
yeah we need to get it done no no we
have the equipment ready okay so our
next one yeah yeah next time we'll have
a calling yeah blessing got us got us
good um jack frost um texas oh i read
that one already stfu ffs um you
understand you never understand if you
don't listen or you don't care silly
sausage harassment is defined as
aggressive
pressure and or intimidation again
conflict avoided is conflict multiplied
men aren't running around like ted bundy
also during that trial the young girls
loved him it was weird token e30 men
self delete because of xx you the uk
economist your female guests should be
ashamed of themselves for their comments
if britain entered world war iii it
would be men who would step up to defend
women the savvy ninja i'm a muscular
good looking guy many women have invaded
my personal space or clients find a way
to grab my biceps it's crazy oh shoot no
i accidentally exited out of it
guys while i'm finding the next super
chat like the video please like the
video
and like we said before if you haven't
if you've watched two or more and you
haven't subscribed it's beef okay
i refuse to suffer the consequences of
bad men throughout human history and the
bad men of every woman's past your fear
usually comes from feminism not reality
stf uffs you can't speak on other
people's experiences the f you can't
tawanna barley who accused four boys of
gang grape was a liar who is used by al
sharpton did the nip pinch bother you
wow hypocrite much matt butcher
my man called 9-1-1 my man called 9-1-1
her fourth offense his wife met
responding police lied swat team came
canine shoot up his arm
his arm bad three felonies all dropped
after four years two trials when the
detective had no evidence monkey usopp
these girls got it so good remember the
batman movie theater shooting all the
men literally shared it shielded their
body on the women sentience women being
touched in essayed are from a small
percentage of bad men majority of men
are willing to stand between you and
those bad actors but a majority of women
are painting the majority of men equal
to the bad men 90 free topay kobe was
falsely accused of grape it was fake
fnuts86 this is the best channel ever i
love your content brick cormier this may
be before many of your guests time
however i have a whole lacrosse team
from duke university that prove women
lie sentience based on this conversation
it's very clear that women are not only
stating the exception but also change
the definitions to fit their whim stats
show that women and men lie for at just
the same percentage just for different
reasons alexander l something the real
men were destroyed by feminist ideology
to pave of the way to a global
authoritative regime the thing the first
thing you must do is review remove this
threat of a rebellion which comes by
strong when um
stfu ffs evidence noun body of facts or
information indicating whether a belief
or proposition is valid or true evidence
neither feelings nor rumors matt butcher
to all the women all the all a woman has
to do is hit 9-1-1 and the guy is left
seeing it first hand in court was
threatened on me but i had the video
desperate and scorned women will do it
no f's given sentience for the woman
who's talking about essay please define
essay because feminism has taken extreme
liberties to redefine and and obscure
the definition of essay and grape look
up the cases of grape most men are named
in shame but the women are named and are
but the women are anonymous
alistar horton any claim without
evidence is worthless dubman pearl when
women claim they've been essayed or
graped asked for details women like to
throw on buzz words for the effect but
when you get to the details you find out
it wasn't even anything close chris c to
the essay stat i've been accused three
times in my work of 20 years each time
they've proven my innocence they all
filed because of my position at the
company death token men who report essay
get laughed at scfu if you have evidence
cops will gleefully arrest offensive
tick tocks just a reminder a touch on
the shoulder is not sa the savvy ninja
the skill dedication and sacrifice it
takes to be an elite gamer no matter the
genre is not comparable to physical
sports
um 90 free tope is is diversity a factor
when ruining the dating game
stf uffs are the are the girls
deliberately answering cues that sarah
didn't ask are they just not a smart
enough to understand him he said does a
man need children and they answered do
children make all men real 90 free to
pay men are hunters women are prey why
is the prey tell why is the prey telling
us how to hunt them sentient through the
inception of civilization fathers took
their sons into the wild and taught them
to be men ergo iron sharpeners air iron
men forge men women have no concept of
men aside from their duty and submission
to one otherwise she will emulate one
matt butcher it may show you are more
responsible to men by not having a child
with a toxic woman
read something pearly you should really
stop looking up looking up these elite
puppets they aren't real laurence
bullock can you ask the women on the
panel do the do women teach men to lie
to them because it is said that women
can't handle the truth
um
do 90 free to payday women love men the
uk economist the pearls looking elegant
and hot today patrick peeling piano the
majority of millionaires are not
self-made they're billionaires lazy men
with generational wealth they get all
the girls is definitely a thing chris
show the entire panel when reading super
chats please some of us want to see the
reactions when they read them
token um men need to realize that they
will never qualify for a top tier men
because they come from the wrong family
social circles are critical red mean
green inner beauty comes from outer
beauty if you want to be beautiful you'd
have to suffer be self aware and
disciplined 90 free tope are girls
attracted to poor guys that but don't
date them because they're too
embarrassed by their peers women don't
love only men love for you
um l.p berkshire oh wait i read this one
already okay let me refresh and just
make sure there aren't any a lot of
super chats yeah we did we did good
today
good today we did good today thank you
everyone for donating yeah thank you
guys these are going to a lot of the
studio upgrades when we move so we want
to get more mics so the people in the
back when we over book they can actually
have an individual mic with like
headphones
and we're moving into a bigger place so
hopefully we can like get a bigger couch
that like everyone can sit on i think
it'd be pretty cool um there's like four
more i'm gonna read really quick hell on
earth gaming if she looks different from
you in the morning she essayed you peter
quid pearl i'm scared i see dead people
you should look you know you should get
i don't know what to tell you
um silly sausage epstein's girls were
paid above the minimum wage they didn't
speak up until they aged out of the
preference range not just joking but
seriously report any weird abstinent
people as fast as you can
um okay that's all of them
right we've been filming for over two
hours ladies and gents um i think after
that we will round up yeah um
yeah let's round up and get your guys
final thoughts on
manhood and what it is to be a real man
we'll go around
okay let's start with yeah what's up so
say manhood is just
being a man you're proud of
being a leader being powerful
and
being yeah pretty much okay
i think being a real man is a man who's
got that provide and protect her
instinct
and also he is ambitious in life where
he works hard to fulfill his mission
um
to me a real man is
a man who's fully in tune with himself
or at least working to be in tune with
himself whether it's financial spiritual
um
psychological emotional mental all of
that good stuff but yeah just being in
tune with yourself
um
say the question again
real man what is it is what is it to be
a real man do you think
just rounding up your final thoughts on
in general i think anyways i just think
being a provider head of the house
um somebody that can pass something on
to your kids
to your wife
that's what i personally feel like so
they must have good values so that they
can do all of those things okay
power leadership
having the ability to go through
into the the ups and downs
in life while
remaining
emotionally stable
because during crazies crazy
times especially in the family we can
talk like put in practice like putting
some scenarios like i don't know fire in
the house heartbreak i've seen a video
where uh the dad and his daughter were
in the kitchen and suddenly earth break
earthquake
so his first instinct was taking the
child away
and making sure that the child was away
and the mother dried afterwards so this
kind of instinct
um
yeah i would say that
okay well thank you all for coming um
thank you all for
tuning in uh thank you all for the
donations please guys can you follow me
okay on my youtube sarah garvey follow
me on all social medias at sarah garvey
thank you all for coming pal do you want
to close out yeah i have a couple super
chats that just came in at the end um
one sentence are always roasting me for
the super chat pearl davis please take a
breath between your super chat's
readings and get a dictionary
look at it okay reading's hard um
anyways um sunny
you know what um sunny you should invite
single mothers to talk about alienation
and sentience what is a real man man all
women should shut up at this point or i
will comment on how a real woman should
be barefoot pregnant and in the kitchen
fixing me a sandwich it's called having
self-restraint and knowing what you
don't know
okay well okay that was the topic today
okay guys um thank you guys so much
couple announcements on the way out just
to as a reminder go subscribe to our
clips channel um we're at 25 000 subs
and you guys did that in like two weeks
which is nuts so let's get to 50 by the
end of the month thank you for that yeah
thank you so much um as for our
memberships um we have a third tier
which you can do a one-on-one call with
me once a month no one signed up yet so
you could be the first it'll be really
exciting um also if you want to see the
new penthouse it's really cool
but we're only showing it on members
only it's ten bucks a month so sign up
for that go follow my instagram it's
just dot pearly things i think i'm at
twenty six 000 followers so it'd be cool
to hit 50 on there i've never i've been
more into instagram lately because they
took away my tick tock so yeah yeah go
oh also
yeah i'm back on tic tac um they took
away my account but they can't keep me
off the app i'm writing at 50k so it's
just pearly things two because they took
away my first one so yeah yeah you could
say i'm creative um the member
jess who's our member of the week i
forgot apa ata okay our member of the
week is ata um you've been really active
in the comments so just noticed and she
picked you and if you want to come on
the show dm eddie the link is in the
description thank you for watching like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel we will talk to you next
time